This is Jocko podcast number
one 61 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening.
Okay.
I do the wrong.
And first begin to brawl the
secret mischiefs that I said,
a brooch I lay unto the
grievous charge of others,
Clarence,
whom I indeed have cast in darkness.
I do bu weep to many simple goals,
namely to Derby Hustings Buckingham and
tell them tis the queen and her allies
that stirred the king against the Duke.
My brother
now they believe it and with all
wet me to be revenged on rivers,
Dorset Gray.
But then I sigh and with a
piece of scripture tell them
that God bids us do good
for evil.
And thus I close my naked villainy with
odd old end stolen out of holy writ and
seen a saint when most I play the devil.
And that right there is a
few lines from the play,
Richard,
the third written by
good old William Shakespeare,
the Bard and
clearly Richard.
The third is uh,
made out in this play to be an evil
like a hundred percent evil political
maneuverer.
That's what he's made out to be.
Sort of the ultimate archetype
of the Mac of Alien Machiavellian
leader.
And there's people that say what
and it's, it's actually, it's see,
certainly seems that Shakespeare
intentionally wrote him that way.
And there's a bunch of things,
I guess at some point we'll go over the
whole play of Richard the third, but
okay,
let's take a look at the lines that debt,
you know,
cause because Machiavellian what we've,
what we think of it when we hear it now
is we think that it means someone that
is just completely devious and completely
dishonest and completely deceitful in
their quest for power. Yeah. Right.
That's what people think of when
they think of Machiavellian. And
definitely I think Richard,
the third is made to be and
was written to be sort of the,
the quintessential
machiavellian character.
Let's look at these lines a
little bit. Um, because as I said,
when we did Henry the
fifth on podcast number 15,
you're not gunna know exactly what
Shakespeare is talking about because he's
writing in an almost in another language.
So not quite,
you can still understand it.
It doesn't take much.
But there's some things going on in there.
So it starts off,
I do the wrong and first begin to brawl.
So was he saying there I am the one
that is doing something that is wrong.
I'm the one that's starting the fights.
Yeah, that's what's going on here.
I'm starting to fights and then he says
the secret mischiefs that I set a brooch,
I lay unto the grievous charge of others.
So these bad behaviors
that he's undertaking that
he's secretly undertaking,
he is blaming them on other people.
He then goes on to say Clarence,
whom I indeed have cast in darkness and
you wouldn't quite understand this but
unless you read it,
but his brother clearance,
he put his brother Clarence into prison
and then he says,
I do blue weep to many simple goals.
So he in front of other people,
he cries and bemoans
that Oh poor clearance.
But he thinks these people are fools,
namely Derby, hustings and Buckingham,
which is what he says in the next line.
And then he says that he
tells those same people,
he tells those people that it's the
queen and her allies. And tell them,
tis the queen and her allies. He's,
he's saying like, look, this is,
this isn't about me. It's about the queen.
She's the one that's doing all this.
She's the one that stir
the king against the Duke,
my brother. So it's not, it's
not my fault. It's the queen.
And then he says, now they
believe it in with all whipped me,
meaning they believe it. And then
they're egging him on like you need.
You can't let that stand. Imagine
that. And then you pick it out,
twist it right there.
Like you're setting this up.
But then you've got these people actually
egging you to take vengeance on the
situation,
which is what they're egging him on to do.
Back to the book to be revenged on rivers,
Dorset Gray.
But then, but then here's where, here's
where it takes a little, a little switch.
But then I sigh and with
a piece of scripture,
so he's going to say, ah, and then
he's going to quote the Bible.
He says,
he tells them that God bids us
do good for evil. You know, hey,
the Bible says we should do good instead
of evil. That's what's going on here.
And then he says,
and thus I clothed my naked villainy.
That's a good line. You kind of be
Shakespeare, right? That one right clove,
my naked villainy.
This is how I dress up.
My evil plans
with odd old ends stolen out of holy writ.
So He dresses up as naked villain,
he covers his evil plans with little
parts of scripture from the Bible.
Then he closes it and seem a
saint when most I play the devil.
So like I said,
that's,
that's Richard the third and things don't
really work out that well in the play
for Richard the third and they don't want,
they didn't work out for
him in real life either.
He was actually hacked to death,
which we generally consider
to be a bad ending.
He was hacked to death at the end of the
battle of Bosworth after he fell off of
his horse. Legit. And there's a famous
line, which I'm sure everyone's heard,
a horse, a horse, my kingdom for a horse,
which is he, he, he was losing everything.
Cause it, he fell off his horse
and needed one. And like I said,
perhaps at some point we'll,
we'll cover the whole play.
But today what I wanted to dig into a
little bit is this term of Machiavellian.
And we covered his art of war book,
which I had an interesting,
um,
I think it was a youtube comment cause I
said, you know, art of war, Machiavelli,
Niccolo Machiavelli and someone's like
a top was written by Sun Su Idiot.
And then some trooper
came on and was like,
actually he's not talking
about that argue for,
he covered that one here and covered
this. Oh and this, by the way,
there's a bunch of different art awards
and here's one of them that was indeed
written by Machiavelli.
So we covered that.
But that's not really a
Machiavelli's most famous work.
His most famous work is this book,
which we mentioned there, the prince
and the prince was thought to
have been written around a 15,
13 not really widely published until
1532 which was five years after
Machiavelli's death.
And it's,
it's basically the fore runner
of kind of leadership bunks,
right,
is the fore runner of self improvement
books and it's telling leaders how to
lead their principalities and it,
and one thing, and I don't dive too,
I don't dive too many of these.
We're not going to cover too many things,
but it gives real world instruction.
So it's kind of like extreme ownership
of the dichotomy of leadership.
It gives real situations that happen.
It gives the principal and then it's like
here's a situation where this actually
unfolded this way.
So it's,
it's a very thorough in that respect and
it's considered to be one of the first
works of modern political philosophy
and it,
this is the thing,
it has the reputation of advising people
to do whatever it takes to gain and
hold power. That's sort of the, that's
when you hear, and in fact the word,
like I said, the word has really negative
connotations. When someone says, oh,
that guy's, I'm back of alien leader. You
don't think, oh that's, that's cool. No,
you think, oh, he's under handed and he's
going to stab people in the back to get,
get where he wants. And there's
definitely some parts and we'll get to it,
but the,
it's not that,
and the approach is much more
balanced than people than people.
Then he has the then then
people generally consider,
it's just a much more balanced perspective
and like anything that talks about
leadership and human nature,
we can learn from it.
So let's go to the book.
The prince by Machiavelli starts off here.
Those who strive to this is, this is
an interesting, he's doing a little,
he does some salesy stuff in here too.
There's a couple of times where I have to,
I had to call it, I'm going
to call him out, all of them,
but he does some Staley's
salesy type stuff in here.
So here's how he starts it off.
Those who strive to obtain the good
graces of a prince are accustomed to come
before him with such things as they hold
most precious on which they see him to
take. Most delight whence
one often sees horses, arms,
cloth of gold,
precious stones.
And similar ornaments presented to
princes worthy of their greatness.
So are we saying, hey, if you want to get
good, you know, good graces with a prince,
you bring him stuff,
horses and gold and whatever.
Then he says, desiring therefore to
present myself to your magnificent,
with some testimony of
my devotion towards you.
I have not found among my possessions
anything which I hold more deer than or
value so much as the knowledge of the
actions of great men acquired by long
experience in contemporary affairs
and to continual study of antiquity,
which having reflected upon and which
having a reflected upon it with great and
prolonged diligence,
I now send digested into a little
volume to your magnificence.
That's pretty, that's pretty cool. He
says, look, I, I could give you gold,
but that's not really what's
valuable to me. What I will do,
the most valuable thing I can give
you is the knowledge that I have,
the knowledge that I've had from
studying and living through these things.
And he continues.
And although I may consider
this work unworthy of your
countenance, nevertheless,
I trust much to you're a benign city,
that it may be acceptable.
Seeing that it is not possible for me
to make a better gift than to offer you
the opportunity under of
understanding in the shortest time.
All that I have learnt in so many years
and with so many troubles and dangers,
which work I have not embellished
with swelling or magnificent words,
nor stuffed with rounded periods.
So he comes out of the gate,
right?
He's pretty arrogant dude.
These saying, listen,
you are so lucky that I went through all
this stuff and I'm just gonna give it
to you. I'm going to give you
this little nice little volume,
very plainly written, which is almost like
an excuse, right? Like there's no, no,
there's no fancy words here. I'm just
giving it to you straight. You know,
I am no Shakespeare while
Shakespeare wasn't even around yet,
but he's saying it's very plainly
written and then he goes into it.
So I think that's a pretty salesy
opening. But Hey, good, good on him.
He's trying to make it happen.
He starts off talking about
the difficulties that it
occur in a new principality
and principalities.
You used that word.
That's the what the
what the book is about.
It's when you take over land from people.
Um,
here we go.
Cool.
Although one may be very strong in armed
forces, yet in entering a province,
one has always need of the
goodwill of the natives.
That's a great statement and
you think about that statement.
Think about it from a
military perspective.
business perspective,
and this is something that
the u s military should
always pay attention to. Hey,
you can be strong in your
armed forces can be strong,
but you need the goodwill of the natives.
Boom. There you go. Let's think about,
let's remember that one in the world.
You, you and we, we know
we do our best to do that.
America does its best to do that, but
we don't always do a good job. Hmm.
And then the other thing
is, when you think about it
from a business perspective,
when you get an acquisition taking place,
like it's cool,
you go in there and you've got all
the money to buy some little company,
but if they all hate you,
nay.
If you don't have the goodwill of
the people that you just bought,
you're going to have some issues. I
promise you you're gonna have some issues.
Yeah.
Okay.
Next up,
those dominions,
which when acquired are added to an
ancient state by him who acquires them are
either of the same country and language
or they are not. So he's saying, look,
when you take someone over there,
either with the same language
or they don't have the same
language when they are,
it is easier to hold them,
especially when they have not been
accustomed to self government.
So if you take someone over and they
speak your language and they've, you know,
you took them over from someone
else that was controlling them,
there'll be okay with that because
they're not used to controlling themselves
anyways.
And then he goes on.
But when states acquired in
a country differing language,
customs or laws,
there are difficulties and good fortune
and great energy are needed to hold them.
And one of the greatest and most real
helps would be that he who has acquired
them should go reside there.
So if they don't speak your language,
if it's different culture,
guess what?
You got to go there and
you got to stay there.
Otherwise it's going to be a problem.
So they're going to move there to
so they can gain more understanding,
gain more understanding and learn
the language and stuff like that.
And also be there because you've gotta,
you gotta be able to pay attention to when
rebellion is going to form against it.
If you're not,
and they speak a different language,
they have a different culture
and you're not in the game blind.
So has some issues. Yeah,
you're going to get blindsided.
So you've got to go in there, got to get
deep. You got to occupy that territory.
Hmm.
Continuing on men,
odd either to be well treated or crushed.
We read that one again.
Men ought either B to be well treated
or crushed because they can avenge
themselves of lighter
injuries of more serious ones.
They cannot,
therefore,
the injury that is to be done to
a man ought to be of such kind.
That one does not stand
in fear of revenge.
So there's kind of classic
Mackey of alien fought.
If you're going to hurt someone,
just completely annihilate them
to the best of your ability.
Don't give them the ability to
come back at you again. Yeah.
And then on the other hand, treat
them super good. Right. So the Tia,
treat her, treat them good,
or you crush them. Yeah.
It's,
it's, it's a, it's a good statement,
right? Yeah. And it takes,
this is something that it
takes, uh, uh, you know,
the will to completely destroy someone.
It takes a lot of gall, right. You have
to have the stomach to be able to do that.
Yeah. And a lot of people don't
have the stomach to do that.
So that's why I would say in most cases
it's better to treat people well and
have them come on board. And he
had actually, he says that too,
but we'll get there.
And back to the book,
in maintaining armed men
there in place of colonies,
one spends much more having
to consume on the garrison,
all of the income from the state so that
the whole acquisition turns into a loss
and many more are exasperated
because the whole state is injured.
That's what he's saying.
So when you do have to go in and you'd
have to smash it and you have to keep
people there to keep smashing, guess
what? You're spending all this money,
you're investing all these people and
it's so hard to keep it under control that
it's not even worth it made the
acquisition turns into a loss.
So from a, from a business
perspective, you go into a company,
you buy them, but then they're rebellious.
So you've got to fire everyone.
They've got to bring people in and
retrain them and you've got to retake
territory.
You lost customers because you cause you
didn't support during that time and so
you invest all this money and guess
what your acquisition ends up becoming a
loss.
Whereas if you had a good relationship
with these people and you went in there
and you,
they were able to kind of come on board
with your culture and the way you were
doing things, all of a sudden you
move into a good scenario. Yeah,
keep it in. Keep, keep it. Okay.
Friendly.
If you can
back to the book what all
prudent Prince's ought to do,
who have to regard not only
present troubles but also
future for which they must
prepare with every energy because when
foreseen it is easy to remedy them,
but if you wait until they approach the
medicine is no longer in time because
the maladies become incurable.
There some good stuff in this
book and this is one of them.
This is kind of obvious,
but hey,
you need to look to the future
and when there's a problem coming,
cut it off early. The earlier you solve
the problem, the easier it's going to be.
He continues for,
it happens in this,
as the physicians say it
happens in hectic fever.
Then in the beginning of the
malady it is easy to cure,
but difficult to detect.
But in the course of time,
not having been either detected
or treating an in the beginning,
it becomes easy to detect,
but difficult to cure.
It's like getting caught in our mock,
right? If you see it coming, it's easy.
You just move your shoulder, you move your
hips a little bit, whatever you're out.
Yeah.
The further it goes down that path,
the worse the situation gets.
Yes, and it's the same thing also,
you know when I've talked about
having hard conversations with people,
the earlier you have
that hard conversation,
the easier the hard conversation is
to have. The longer you let it go.
Not only is it a harder conversation,
but it's a conversation that's going
to disrupt and cause more problems.
It's going to interfere with
our relationship. If, if I'm,
if I have to have a hard
conversation with you,
are really are our relationship
and isn't getting better, right?
It's getting worse. So the ease, the
earlier you could solve these problems,
the better off you're going to be.
It continues this,
it happens in affairs of state for when
the evils that arise have been foreseen,
which it is only given to a wise man
to see. They can be quickly redressed,
but when through not having been foreseen,
they have been permitted to grow in
a way that everyone can see them.
There is no longer a remedy.
Keep your ears to the ground so you've
got to hear what's coming. Therefore,
the Romans for seeing troubles dealt
with them at once and even to avoid a war
would not let them come to a head for,
they knew that war is not to be avoided,
but is only to be put off
to the advantage of others.
So every time you delay in
getting that problem solved,
you're not helping yourself. Hmm.
That's a good way to think about that.
I haven't really thought about
that way before. You know, I,
I talk about the hard conversations have
earlier. They're going to be easier.
The only,
if you're putting those those wars off,
you're only helping the other person.
You're always putting yourself
in a worse situation. Okay.
So the other person meaning the enemy.
Yeah. Yeah. You're only helping the enemy.
Hm.
So attack those problems. Look, well, I
think the first thing is pay attention,
right?
You've got to pay attention to these
problems that could be arising hard to
detect,
hard to you and yeah,
and then I like he says it when everyone
can see them, it's too late. Yeah.
So you gotta be gathering intelligence.
You gotta be paying attention
back to the book because one can easily
entered there by gaining over some
barren of the kingdom for one always
finds malcontents and such as desire a
change. So he's talking about
when you're taking someone,
when you're taking over like a kingdom,
you,
you can always find some people in the
kingdom that are of not happy with the
situation. Like you can go into a company
and you can say, it seems like your,
the way your processes work
is a real hard on you guys.
It seems like they're not really in vet.
You can always find some people
that are mad inside of a kingdom.
That's what he's saying. He's saying
to find them. Yeah, he, well, he,
here's what he goes on.
He says such men for the reasons given
can open the way into a state and render
victory easy.
But if you wish to hold it afterwards,
you meet with infinite difficulties,
both from those you have assisted
and those you have crushed.
Nor is it enough for you
to have exterminated the
family of the prints because
the Lord's that remain make themselves
the heads of fresh movements against you.
And as you are unable to either
satisfy or exterminate them,
the state is lost whenever the
time brings the opportunity.
What you're dealing with there,
if you're entering,
if you find some people that are disloyal
inside of a company and then you go
and become friends with them and then
you go in and take the company over,
there is a chance. And what he's
saying is like that disloyalty is,
is a trait and they're going
to be disloyal to you. So
you need to, and you can't,
you can't crush them.
You can't exterminate them because the,
you've developed a relationship with
them and at the same time you can't trust
them.
So be careful with that.
Back to the book,
whenever those states which have been
oc had been acquired as stated above,
have been accustomed to live under
their own laws and in freedom,
there are three courses for
those who wished to hold them.
So obviously I'm skipping
big chunks of the book, but
what he's talking about is when you've
taken over somewhere that is used to
having their own laws and used to living
in freedom, there's three different,
three different methods or approaches you
can take if you want to hang onto him.
Here we go.
The first is to ruin them.
The next is to reside there in person.
The third is to permit them
to live under their own laws,
drawing attribute and establishing
within it an oligarchy which will keep it
friendly to you. Very clever, very clever,
very smart too. And I see the, again,
I keep going back to business
a lot because when you,
when you're dealing with a company
that acquires other companies,
like this is very real. If you've
got a company, let's say you acquire,
if you acquire part of,
let's say you acquire part of a
company that's been run by some, uh,
senior company,
like a parent company,
they're not used to making
their own decisions. So when
you come in and say, Hey,
now we're not going to help you
out and we're gonna, you know,
you're going to be kind of going along
with us. Now you're under our command.
If they're used to being commanded,
they're like, okay, new boss,
but we will deal with it. But
if they're, if they've been,
if they were their own company,
they were,
they were on their own and they were
doing whatever they wanted and they were
living in total freedom and now you come
in and see you and now you got start
listening to my rules. Yeah.
It's going to be a problem. Yes.
I don't agree with the fact
that you have to crush them.
I would prefer that you go in
and form a relationship with him.
But what he's saying is,
look, if you go in there,
so let's Say I took over echoes company
and you are used to freedom and I was
just like, hey echo, here's what's going
on. Hey, here's some broad guidance,
but I really like what you're doing.
Keep doing it, man. Keep doing it.
And then you know,
here's what you're gonna pay me
because I'm giving you some support.
And you'd be like, okay.
Now what I will say,
which he doesn't go into is over time
I can start to get, first of all,
build a relationship with you.
Once I build a relationship with you,
then I can start saying, hey, echo,
have you thought about doing this a little
bit different over here and hey, echo,
what do you about this? And Hey, echo,
this other company that we own does
it this way and it's really efficient.
Would you consider maybe seeing how that
would work inside your, with your team?
Yeah. And so I would slowly move, but
for me to come in and say, okay, Aca,
we just closed the deal. Here's the
new yes, that's when you go, hey,
you go to your troops and see,
I don't know if this was a good call
and I don't know what these guys think.
They know everything. And now listen,
we got a rebellion on our hands.
So now I might have to crush it.
My credit,
the whole idea of crushing seems pretty
old school. Yeah, yeah. Well, and,
and as he said,
when once you crush something,
well then you've got to invest all
kinds of things in it too. Like, Hey,
so let's say, let's say I bought
your company and then you, you know,
you rebelled against me, so I fired you.
Well now I've got to bring someone on.
I've got to find someone that understands
your business and the intricacies of
your business. And guess what?
That's not easy. And it, guess what?
Now I've got to invest all this time
and myself and I've got to bring some,
some contractors in there to help out.
Um, next thing you know, I'm upside down.
Whereas if I had just done a
good deal with you and you know,
kind of let you run things for awhile
and let build a relationship so that you
actually would want to listen
to me, that's different.
That's better. Yeah. So yes,
the idea of crushing people,
generally it's your, it's,
it's not the preferred method. It's not
ideal. Generally. Sometimes is required.
Yes. Sometimes people need to get
destroyed. That's, that's the way it is.
And when that's the way, cool.
That's a lock and load destroyed.
Did you used to watch football
or do you watch football?
I don't watch much football. Ronnie
Lott is, he's old school. Yes I do.
A lot. Is 40 niners packaged then? I
Dunno if this is true, but it's a rumor.
I Dunno.
This is what I heard when I was
young, where he would like, he broke
his finger, pinky or I don't know,
one of his fingers. He broke it. And you
know, he's trying to, you know, play,
you gotta play as a
professional football player,
so you can't just be out because
of your finger. So he play,
you tape it up and it kept just getting
jammed up so he just cut it off.
So it's kind of one of those deals,
you know where you know,
yeah get rid of the finger but you don't
have a finger. But if the thing is like,
you know, jamming you up too much by
being there, then you got to crush it.
I heard a story,
similar story about village
village Ismail do you know crazy
Jujitsu player. Great Jujitsu player.
But he had crazy a cauliflower ears.
Yeah.
They just look like to bring to the half
tennis half baseball's on either side
of his head.
And I heard a story about him that he
was just asking the doctor just caught
them off, cut off, cut them off,
just get rid of them. No use.
All they do is causing me problems.
Just get rid of them. Yeah.
So is that considered a
hardcore kind of yeah,
cause I'm sure that, well then again I
guess it depends on the problems, right?
I mean cause that's, what are
your ears do for you? And I guess,
I guess they catch some sound
and bring it into your ears. Yes.
But if you're not hunting right and you
don't necessarily need to hear super
well,
and by the way,
once you have calling photos and it
starts going into your ear a little bit,
that's not good either for your, for your
hearing. So his hearing might improve.
Just get rid of those things. Yeah.
I guess it depends how bad is coming.
You know what I'm saying? I didn't know
what you're saying. Yeah. You know,
cutting off your years, it's a lot
more that goes into that then a finger,
I think, because you know, I don't know.
I mean on a social level, you know,
you get a guy who was, his ears cut off
on purpose, by the way. It's kind of like,
okay,
let's say you're a girl and you're like,
Hey mom, dad, boyfriend.
Have you never thought about like when if
you've read a cauliflower ear? No. Okay.
Sometimes when you get cauliflower ear
and it's preventing you from trading,
there's, there's no doubt that the
thought goes through your mind like,
you know what? Hey, I'm
in the game. You know,
these things aren't doing me much good.
Let me just get rid of these. Yes,
I could see how that could be, I guess,
but sorry man, I can't get there.
Not with the ears. Maybe the fingers. I
dig the fingers for sure. So you can't,
there's certain things you can't do if
you lose your fingers. I he play guitar.
Yeah. You're going to be a
problem in gym. So I keep,
I keep the fingers more than the ears.
The choice.
Here's your fingers. I don't
mind. You know what, you're,
you're more sensitive to your appearance
I think than I am aesthetically
conscious. Yeah, I would agree
with that, sir. Yes, I think so.
So you get your ears. I'm
keeping my fingers. Yes.
Like a hammer on that gift box deal.
Well that went off the rails a little bit.
All right.
Going back to the,
a wise man ought always to follow the
paths beaten by great men and to imitate
those who have been supreme so that
if his ability to does not equal,
there's at least it will savor of it.
Let him act like the clever archers who,
this is a good little statement,
let him act like the clever archers
who designed to hit the mark,
which yet appears too far distant.
And knowing the limits to
which the strength of their
bow attains tank take aim
much higher than the mark.
Not to reach them by their strengths
or Arrow to so great a height,
but to be able to with the aid of so
high and aim hit the mark they which they
wish to reach. That's a very clever
way of putting it. Yeah. Hey look,
if I don't think I can hit this mark,
I'm just going to aim a little bit higher
and then even though I might not reach
the highest mark, I'll at
least hit the mark. I was,
I'll get where I want to
be and yeah. Yeah. Fully.
That's a good way to go
through life. Yeah. There's
a lot of that. I mean that's,
you know, that's a tactic, technique,
whatever and like a lot of things like
negotiation and they say they'd do the
same thing. Right. Okay. I
want to get, you know, I don't
know, you go job interview,
whatever.
I want to make 100,000 so I'm going
to ask for like one 20 he's going to
negotiate it down and I get my hundred.
No, that's true. Where this thing,
I think sometimes people get this
out of hand is it'll be like a sales
organization and they'll say,
you know, they want to bring in,
they want to do $5 million worth of
sales in the next month. And so they say,
okay guys,
this is what we're gonna do 10 million.
And they set an unrealistic goal.
When you set an unrealistic
goal that's not achievable.
It's basically a meaningless goal.
So you have to,
you have to aim a little bit high,
but it's gotta be realistic. Yeah.
Yeah.
I would think you knew,
I'm just going off how I felt
right there when you said that, uh,
if someone sets an unrealistic goal,
especially for you, that includes you,
you know,
where like the failure of reaching
that goal is kind of partly or failure.
I think you'd kind of decrease
my enthusiasm for those deals to,
that's why people need to be very
careful in how they set their goals,
that they set them high
enough that it, it, it,
you try and get to it and maybe you don't
quite get there because let's face it,
if you set a goal and
you just easily make it,
you should have set your goal
a little bit higher. You know,
if you set a goal and is not even
close, no one even tries. Yeah.
So you've got to set a realistic goal.
Yeah. Yeah. It was not going to work well.
Yeah.
And like people will be
like salt especially at work
when people start setting
goals all crazy like crazy. That's
what I was talking to me. Yeah.
Well I was just watching the movie
major league. Remember that on the old,
the first one I tried to remember
what it was about and they were like,
baseball is this where they,
the owner was trying to like
sell the team or something.
But for her to do that they had to like
lose a games or something like that.
And if they didn't lose in,
she would just replace the players with
other players who would lose, you know,
kind of thing.
So it was a,
so everyone knows all down about
it in the garbage truck. Well,
there's only one thing to do when the
whole thing, you know, like that, right,
which is, I dig it. Right.
Um, but at like a regular job,
well,
it was for the movie to obviously,
so you've got to tap in
inspirational storyline. But
anyway, at your job, you know,
let's say there's numbers week
and then it's like, okay, Dang,
you're making me meet these crazy numbers.
And they're unrealistic.
They're above a normal good goal.
They're way above. So it's like, okay,
what does this mean now? Now like probably
get, can't spend time with my family.
Okay,
now you're going to freaking dryness
into the ground working and do all this
stuff or whatever. Going against my
interests, you know, as a human being.
So I'm gonna feel junk about that. I'm
not going to like that. No, no one does.
That's my point.
Does even no one likes in the
business world and no one liked it.
It made your leisure either
as well. That was, you know,
they did like it. Check.
All right, moving on.
Now as the fact of becoming a prince
from private station presupposes either
ability or fortunate and he uses the f
word fortunate lot to mean like pretty
much luck.
It is clear that one or the other of
these things will mitigate in some degree
many difficulties.
Nevertheless,
he was relied least on fortune
is established the strongest.
Make sense? So when you, when you're in a
leadership position, if you've got there,
cause you're lucky,
it's going to be harder for you to
maintain a good position as a leader.
You've got there because of
your skill and what does it,
what's the other thing he says?
Because your ability, if you get there,
cause your ability, people are
gonna respect you more. It just,
you just got there by luck.
Those who buy valorous ways become
princes acquire a principality with
difficulty,
but they keep it with ease.
The difficulties they have in acquiring
it rise in part from the new rules.
And method methods,
which they are forced to introduce
to establish their government and its
security.
So when you have a hard time getting
into power and you do it by boldness,
once you're there,
it's going to be easier for you to do
it because you had to make all these
maneuvers. You're to figure things
out in order to get their continuing,
and it ought to be remembered that
there is nothing more difficult.
This is a good one. There is nothing
more difficult to take in hand,
more perilous to conduct or more uncertain
in its success than to take the lead
in the introduction of
a new order of things.
So there's nothing harder than trying
to come in and introduce a new order of
things. Nothing harder than
that. And here's the reasons,
because the innovator has for enemies,
all those who have done well under the
old conditions and Luke warm defenders in
those who may do well under the new.
So you got people that are
entrenched that like, hey man,
we've been doing this for 20 years.
I'm not changing it.
And he got someone else saying, well
it could work better. That's like,
it's not a good comparison. It's
not a, it's not a fair fight. Yeah.
Cause those people that are already
know it works. They know it works. Yeah.
You got someone that I think the new
thing will work. It's a mismatch.
Continuing on.
This coolness arises partly from fear
of the opponents who have the laws on
their side and partly from the incredulous
incredulous of men who do not readily
believe in new things until they
have had long experience of them.
So you got people that have been
doing this forever. Like I just said,
you've got someone that's hasn't really
figured out if there's new things going
to work and it's just a mismatch.
So
they're skeptical.
Okay.
Continuing those who solely by good
fortune become princes from being private
citizens have little trouble in rising
but much trouble in keeping a top.
They have not had any d any difficulties
on the way up because they fly.
But they have many, when they reached
the summit, this is a good one.
The people that kind of get lucky and
ended up in a, in a senior position,
in a leadership position, they got lucky.
And so there's no trouble getting there.
They got lucky. They flew there. Yeah.
But then he says they have trouble when
they reached the summit. Continue on.
Such are those to whom some state is
given either for money or by favor of him,
of Him who bestows it.
So
you know,
you see this going through buds actually
there's some people that were like
incredible athletes and they never failed
anything before in their life and all
of a sudden they show up and they start
failing things and it breaks them. Yeah.
Or they're great athletes
going through buds.
And it's because if you're a great
athlete, will and buds is kind of easy.
And then you show up at a seal team.
Things aren't easy because it's not just
athletics in the seal teams and it's
not an athletic game. And the
Sealer, as a matter of fact,
I was just talking about
this the other day,
the athletic capability of,
of a seal or have a special
operations. It's like, sure,
you get some great athletes in there,
but you put on a rucksack and Hump,
you know,
10 kilometers, that's not
an athletically gifted. You,
you as an athletic, there's not
an athletic skill test. Yeah.
You know, it's, it's not like, yeah,
you gotta be in good shape for sure.
But whether this guy played college
football and this guy didn't,
where you put on that rucksack and start
start humping, you can't tell who's who.
Yeah. You know, occasionally you
might be able to, you got to you,
you can make some assumptions that
the have to get the a football player,
you know,
he's an athletic person but
it's not an athletic game.
Yeah. The uh, the same
with like shooting. Okay.
You get someone that's got
great hand eye coordination,
they're probably going to be a pretty
good shot. Not necessarily though.
I knew some guys that were great
athletes weren't good shots. Yeah.
And vice versa. Newsome guys that were
great athletes and they were great shots.
They'd great hand eye coordination.
So it's not really,
there's not really this
athletic challenge.
So my point is you get someone that's
sales through buds because they're a great
athlete cause cause buds is more of
an athletic pursuit. I mean it's like,
okay you gotta run, you got to do pull,
you got to do the opposite course.
There's more athleticism
involved in getting through buds.
Once you get through buds then it's like,
oh you have to think and you have to
gut through hard things a while you're
thinking. So there's some
guys that I went through with,
it got a little tripped up
when they got to the teams,
even though they did not have
a hard time at all with buds,
they got to the teams, they get
tripped up on things because they just,
they just kind of gotten their own way.
You know? Unfortunately. Good, good guys,
hard guys.
But you just think man,
just you need to think a little bit
more dealing with certain mental anguish
while you do other things.
Dealing with it. Yeah,
you got to make decisions
when you're tired,
you got to stay awake when you're tired.
You got to, yeah, like all those things.
Oh there's stress going on. And
you're freaking out. Well, guess what?
You still got to decide that you've got
to make something happen and you've got
to go do it. Yeah. Where it's
easy to just go curl up in a ball,
take a nap. Yeah. Yeah.
Continuing such and he's talking about
these people that were kind of given luck
or or bought their way into the position.
Such stand simply elevated upon the
goodwill and the fortune of him who has
elevated them to most
inconsistent and unstable things.
Neither have they the knowledge requisite
for the position because unless they
are men of great worth and ability
does not reasonable to expect that they
should know how to command.
Having always lived in private condition.
So you get somebody
that gets thrown into a,
to a leadership position and they haven't
done anything to earn their position
here. They're going to be an experience
going to be hard for him. Yeah.
Same thing with the, I mean you
maybe see it now, maybe you don't,
but are injured you to where you know the,
you know,
a young guy or whatever,
he'll, he'll, or he'll have a certain
body type or audit or whatever.
He'll develop like this certain move
that'll be kind of new to everyone.
Like no one's ever seen these,
this system or this new move or whatever.
And they'll get guys get guys in and
win tournaments and start winning
tournaments and the instructor's
like, Dang, this guy's
killing these tournaments.
Hey, let's give him his blue belt,
Brown belt. You know, all the way up.
He gets his like brown belt,
black belt because he wins tournament
more so then because of like his whole
rounded skill set and knowledge.
So kind of makes
sense. Right? I mean shoot,
if a man, if he's willing,
if he's tapping everyone out
in the tournament in, you
know, all the lower belts,
of course we can get you to spell it.
Makes Sense. But later on, you know,
as time goes on and one of
the things it's like, okay,
they'll just figure out the move,
figured out that the answer to that move,
what else is left?
Nothing crazy.
That if you know the move,
like isn't it crazy and you first of all,
but if you don't how to defend something,
you can stop. If you don't know it,
you get tapped. If you know it, you can
get out. Yes. That's so crazy. Yeah. And,
and what's really crazy
is that's the way life is.
That's the way leadership is.
Like when I talked to companies and I'll
be talking to some leader and I'm like,
Hey, here's what you need to say
in a situation like this. And it's,
it's like they can now escape
this position that they're
in. Yes. Cause they can,
oh, oh yeah, here's what you
should say. Yeah. And they say, ah,
you can see it. Look in their eyes.
And then they'll call me and say, dude,
I did that team turned
around and said, oh yeah.
Big shocker man.
There's moves that you can make.
There's tactical maneuvers that you can
make and if you know them, you will,
you'll escape the position. If you don't
know them, you'll get destroyed. Yeah.
And so to,
to where you're going with
this is sometimes somebody
develops something where
they get really good at something and
as soon as soon as some people know it's
coming,
you know,
they can just stop it and then all of
a sudden they start losing tournaments.
They get to purple belt,
they start losing journalists because
of how I was going to say, see,
it's unrealistic in my opinion,
that someone would be really good at a
move and go all the way to black belt
based on that move. That's not realistic.
Yeah. They'll get somebody will,
people will figure it out and they'll
have to round out their game before they
get brown belt. Black belt. You were
getting a little crazy there. Yeah, no,
for the example. But there is this
one, and I don't know the girl's name,
but it was um, it was, I dunno, like I
was saying, but she was a brown belt,
but she had been a brown belt. Like
she, it took her like two years or so.
It's something super fast to get to
Brown. We get to brown belt because of, I,
if I'm not mistaken, she would do
like a reverse triangle all the time.
Maybe a regular triangle. I'm not
sure. And then um, I dunno then I think
I could be getting the names wrong,
but I think it was penny Thomas and she
ended up fighting for Bennie Thompson.
Bennie Thompson beat her and you
know, you know, the new hotness,
the new girl coming up or whatever.
And um,
I think it was Joel who mentioned like
this exact thing that he's talking about
where it's like, yeah, like to be a real
brown belt and compete at the top level,
you got to have a well rounded
game essentially. You know,
because you can't just,
you can't just like what you said,
like you make it up the Brown and black
for a reason. Brown and black belt.
You can't just do it with one move
cause that's not what a brown belt.
And that's when you get
someone that's really good.
They know about all the
different moves. You know, it's,
it always surprises me dean will be able
to answer a question about moves that
he doesn't actually do in
a normal basis. Yeah, yeah.
He knows exactly how to do it.
He knows how to defend it.
He knows how to set it up, but he doesn't
actually do that move and, and that's,
that's how good you got to be.
The other weird thing is you get,
you catch someone like dean in
a position that's totally new,
you know,
just some random and he actually knows
like a thing to do to get out of it,
you know, and you think, how
do you, how do you know that,
you know, some weird like leg
ride position. He's like, Oh,
if you turn your knee outward and then
you pinch your ankles, you'll, you'll,
it'll make them adjust lead.
You can come up on the arm and you
can get out and you're like, wait,
how do you know that?
I've never been in this position.
I've been doing Jujitsu for 25 years and
I've never been this position before.
And now you're telling me that this is
just you, you know this and he probably,
some of these positions
he's probably never been in.
It's like codes like writing code where
if you kind of know the certain like
general rules to things, you
can start figuring it out,
figuring it out. You know,
like, and someone like Dean who was
like, that's optional, Dude. No,
but that's a thing.
There's a difference between what I'm
talking about because what I'm talking
about is he actually knows
specifically, he's not like, hey,
here's what would work based on the
general rules of grappling. It's like, no,
here's what you do in
this specific situation.
That is weird. Yeah. But that's
just completely well rounded. Yeah.
That's just completely well rounded.
You're saying at some point he has had
that experience with that move. Yes.
He's done it some way or
another and he said, oh,
or he's done a much narrower approach
of what you're talking about. Like he,
he's not, maybe not that exact thing,
but it's so close to it. He's like,
here's what happens. Here's
what's going on. Yeah. Yeah.
Similar but not the same. Like he goes
beyond just having the principles.
It's like principals coupled
with experience coupled
with knowledge and dean's
mind for that is,
it's really,
it's crazy uncanny with that as far as
like kids' knowledge and what he can sort
of figure it out or whatever.
It's almost like while you're
doing what you do during the day,
he's like in a room
just thinking about it.
You would think you will think that you
would think that he's sitting around
with like four screens,
like youtube screens and he's watching
different things at once and then he has
some sort of like weird, uh, uh,
control where he can view different
angles and comprehend them. But no,
he has a weird, because I
know he doesn't do that. Yeah.
He used to do it though,
but he has a weird, um,
he, he's got his mind. It's just
made to do that. His mind is just,
has a greater understanding of it than
a normal person and even an abnormal
person. Yeah. But yeah, that makes
sense. Like, you know, if you're,
if you're thorough or thoroughly trained
or have a lot of experience and you've
been through the pitfalls
ups, downs, you know,
you kinda that that light is kind of on
for you. But if you just sorta lock out,
well yeah.
You know,
we work with companies who work with like
startup companies where it's not that
the people haven't scrapped to
get where they are, but you know,
you get funded and you got 12 people on
your team and then all of a sudden you
get a massive funding and you're expecting
to roll into production of something
and,
and you look up and you got 180 people,
you don't have any experience as a
leader and you're expected to lead.
And that's,
you know,
a situation that echelon
front gets involved in because
the investors will come
and say, hey look, we got these guys
over here. They're awesome guys.
They're working hard. Guess what?
They got propelled in this position.
They're awesome at their job. They don't
know how to lead yet. Can you help them?
Yes. That's what we do Roland,
and make it happen. Make sense?
You can't expect someone to know how
to lead if they've never been in a
leadership position before. Can
some people pull it off? Yes.
It's not a big number though.
It's not a big number.
Continuing. Ooh, this is a good one.
He who has not first laid his foundations
may be able with great ability to lay
them afterwards,
but they will be laid with trouble to
the architect and danger to the building.
So lay a good foundation.
This is another,
another thing that's important
when it comes to Jujitsu,
don't be learning the Gogo Blada day four,
but they're just so fun.
I know people want to learn that Gogo
Plata and they don't know how to do a
straight arm lock. Yeah, that's a
problem. And that's why though, right?
I mean even like this,
that's why like people won't focus
on the foundation because it's like,
that part's not as like fun short
term payoff types of Richard area.
It's more fun. It's go, go,
go. Plata is more fun. Whoa,
look at that. It looks fancy.
It looks cool. It's like,
um, I think it was dean with,
he was teaching a class and
he was teaching them how
to fall or something like
that. Not for a long time, just
a little bit. And then, uh,
he was teaching like a
position and whatever. This
is actually a while ago. Uh,
and then towards the end he was like,
all right. All right. All right. Nope.
The kind of like no one said
anything like, Hey, when
are we going to learn blah,
blah, blah. And no one said anything.
He but dean said it as
if people were saying,
well when are we gonna learn something
fun kind of thing. So Tina was like,
all right, all right, I'll
teach you a submission. You
kind of like, cause he knew,
he knows like the submission hold
is the fun part to learn in Jujitsu.
I mean as far as the spectrum,
when you start yes. When you
start. Yeah, yeah. Fully,
fully. Cause you just,
you know, you think,
oh I don't understand why it's good
for me to lay this way on some other or
shrimp across the room.
Like what the heck is that?
That's laying a good foundation.
That's what that is.
Otherwise you've got to do it in.
It's going to be hard to do.
The same thing with businesses.
When you start a business,
start it with a good foundation so you
don't have to go back in there afterwards
and perform surgery on something that's
already been constructed. All right,
now this is Mackey of alien
in a pretty serious way.
The name of this one is
called, or this is, I would say this
is kind of what stems some of you,
the reputation concerning those who have
obtained a principality by wickedness,
but,
and I say this establishes,
but this actually goes
against sort of that standard
machiavellian attitude.
So here we go.
This is one of the historical
examples that he gives that I'm
actually gonna read because it's pretty,
pretty cool.
A gaff Achilles.
The Sicilian became king of Syracuse,
not only from a private,
but from a low, an abject position.
This man, the son of a potter,
through all the changes in his
fortunes always led an infamous life.
Nevertheless, he accompanied his infamous
with so much ability of mind and body,
having devoted himself to
the military profession.
He rose through the ranks to be prayed
or of Syracuse being established in that
position and having deliberately resolved
to make himself prince and to seize by
violence without obligation to others,
that which had been
conceited to him by a cent.
He came to an understanding
for this purpose with the,
with Ama car,
the car theny Jin,
who with his army was fighting in Sicily.
One morning he assembled the people and
the Senate of Syracuse as if he had to
discuss with them things relating to
the republic and at a given signal,
the soldiers killed all the senators and
the richest of the people, these dead.
He seized and held the Princeton of
that city without any civil commotion.
And although he was twice
routed by the Carthaginians,
he ultimately and ultimately besieged.
Yet not only was he
able to defend his city,
but leaving part of his men
for its defense with others,
he attacked Africa and in a short
time raised the siege of Syracuse.
The Carthaginians reduced
to extreme necessity.
We're compelled to come to terms with a
golf Achilles and leaving Sicily to him
had to be content with
the possession of Africa.
So this guy is,
is just gets after it and destroys people
and kills people in order to get into
a good position. Now, you might think that
Machiavelli would say, hey, that's great.
Here's what it actually
says back to the book.
Yet it cannot be called talent to slay
fellow citizens to deceive friends,
to be without faith, without
mercy, without religion.
Such methods may gain empire,
but not glory.
Still.
If the courage of a gothic please in
entering into the end and extricated
himself from the dangers be considered
together with his greatness of mind in
enduring and overcoming hardships,
it can not be seen. Why?
He should be less esteemed than the
most notable captain. Oh, there he is,
giving him more credit,
but then he goes back again.
Nevertheless has barbarous, cruelty and
inhumanity with infinite wickedness.
Do not permit him to be celebrated
among the most excellent men.
What he had treated can,
what do you achieved?
CanNot be attributed to
either fortune or genius.
Yeah.
So, and I'll go one step further
because this is what I think.
I think that when you behave in that
manner, it'll come back to you. Yeah.
It'll come back to you tonight.
I'm not saying there's going to
come back to the karmic way, dude.
That's not what I'm saying.
I'm saying when you,
when you inflict damage on people,
they remember it.
And there will be a time in some point
when they will have the opportunity to be
rain down. Vengeance upon you. Yeah.
So if you act that way, you're gonna,
you're gonna get yours.
And so if you treat people with respect
and you treat people as you would like
to be treated,
then it's fine.
And when the opportunity
arises for them to cross you,
they'll remember how you treated them and
you treat them well and they say, okay,
you know what?
We're going to give this guy a pass.
But when you screw people over,
they're going to screw you back. Yeah.
At some point.
Yeah.
Continuing on. It has to be
remarked that in seizing a state,
the usurper ought to examine
closely all those injuries,
which it is necessary for him to inflict
and do them all at one stroke so as to
not have to repeat them daily.
And thus by not unsettling men,
he will be able to reassure them
and win them to himself by benefits.
This is a good one. If you're
gonna, if you got to cause damage,
rip the bandaid off.
That's what he's saying it all at once.
So if you're going into a
business and you're like, okay,
we're going to have to
eliminate some people.
Don't eliminate two guys today and then
two guys in a week and then three days,
three guys in a month, and then three
people in two weeks in and you just,
everyone now everyone's walking around,
they're scared of getting destroyed,
they're scared of getting
fired. They don't trust you.
You go in, you go, okay, hey,
here's, sorry. Hey, there's some changes.
There's some reductions we've got to make.
Here it is. There's 28 people.
They're going away. What's left?
We're going to go forward.
Or when you conquer. Yeah.
He who does otherwise either from Tim
[inaudible] or evil advice is always
compelled to keep the knife in his hand.
Right.
Neither can he rely on his subjects,
nor can they attach themselves to him
owing to their continued and repeated
wrongs. So you keep stabbing people
every once in a while. Every two,
three days I cut someone's head off.
Yeah. These guys are just, you know,
first of all,
I got to walk around with a knife all
the time and they're thinking, oh,
I see what he's all about.
Yeah.
Continuing for injuries ought
to be done all at one time.
That being tasted less,
they offend less benefits ought to be
given little by little so that the flavors
of them may last longer.
Oh,
so you don't go and give everyone a
yearly bonus at the beginning of the year.
Hey, here's all this money.
No. You Go, hey look,
there's a good quarter or good month
last month. Coddle something for you.
Yup. That tastes last long. If it does,
uh, I recommend that with children, by the
way. Okay, good to know what I'm saying.
Yes. You don't give them the
big reward, you make them.
You got to earn it to get it. Earn it.
Yeah. Keep it going. Keep it going. Yeah.
Continuing and above all things,
a print art to live amongst his people
in such a way that no unexpected
circumstances,
whether of good or evil
shall make him change.
Okay.
Because if the necessity for
this comes in troubled times,
you are too late for harsh measures
and mild ones will not help you for,
they will be considered as forced
from you and no one will be under any
obligation to you for them.
So what are you saying?
There's stay balanced.
So if you,
if things are going well in your
company and you're like, Hey,
bonuses all around and then all
of a sudden things get lean.
I knew I a no more bonuses or
the other hand is like, oh,
things are going rough and like we're
not giving anyone anything. Hmm.
What you need to do is stay
balanced. Hey, here's the budget.
Here's our projected budget.
Here's what we're going to give out.
Here's what we're planning to give out.
It may vary a little bit on, you know,
up or down from there depending on the
market and depending on how we're doing
it, depending on what the future
look like, you want to be balanced.
Don't go hardcore in one
extreme or the other. Yeah.
Okay.
Next
we're a leading citizen,
becomes the prince of his country, not by
wickedness or any intolerable violence,
but by the favor of his fellow citizens.
This may be called a civil principality,
nor is genius or fortune
altogether necessary to attain it,
but rather a happy shrewdness.
And this seems to be the
most positive thing that he,
this happy shoot. It's like,
oh, you're making good
decisions, shrewd decisions.
And that's how you come into power
and people aren't happy with it.
Like that seems like the best possible
way to take over a cool according to this
continuing one, cannot buy fair
dealing and without injury to others.
Satisfy the nobles.
But if you can satisfy the people for
their object as more righteous than that
of the nobles,
the latter wishing to oppress and the
former only desire not to be oppressed.
So who's more important? The nobles
or the people. The people, yeah,
that's not very machiavellian or
it's not the tradition machiavellian.
Thank you.
Consideration.
It is to be added also that a prince can
never secure himself against a hostile
people because of there being too many.
Whilst from Noble's he can secure
himself as they are few in number
make a connection with
your people continuing.
The worst that a prince may expect from
a hostile people is to be abandoned by
them but from hostile nobles he has not
only to fear abandonment but also that
they will rise against him for they
being in these affairs more far.
Seeing in a student always come forward
in a time to save themselves and to
obtain favors from him whom they expect
to prevail and he goes on about these
nobles a little bit more. Nobles ought
to be looked at mainly in two ways.
They either shape their course in such
a way as binds them entirely to your
fortune or they don't.
So there's two D,
Two different kinds of
people you'll have with you.
People that just get on
board or don't they get off?
They get on board or they don't.
And then he says when for
their own ambitious ends,
they shun binding themselves.
It is a token that they are giving more
thought to themselves than to you and to
prince ought to guard against such
and to fear them as if they were open
enemies.
Because in adversity they
will always help to ruin you.
Someone that's not on board,
someone that's looking out for themselves,
someone that's looking out for
themselves and not looking out for you.
It's a problem.
Real problem.
It's an you treat them like
an open enemy or view them.
Fear them as if they're are an open enemy.
Yeah.
And then he continues.
But one who in opposition to the people
becomes a prince by the favor of nobles
ought above everything seek to
win the people over to himself.
And this he may easily do if he
takes them under his protection
because men,
when they receive good from him of whom
they were expecting evil are more bound,
are bound more closely
than to their benefactor.
Thus people quickly become more
devoted to him. So, well, he, again,
he's all about connecting with the troops,
connecting with the troops.
And if they think you're going to treat
them like crap and then you treat them
well, they're like doubly
devoted to you. It feels better.
That's the expectation thing. See,
and I can explain that to you too,
with the, with comfort, you
know, like, you know, you can,
if you're in bed
and then
you know, you hear, I don't know,
chicken outside or something or like a
chain saw like a block away or something,
you're like,
ah,
I can't relax with that noise or
whatever because you expect to be real
comfortable,
your bed kind
of thing.
But you go land some chair or sit
on a chair in and it's surprisingly
comfortable bra,
you'll fall asleep real quick.
So it's Kinda the same deal with the
people though. Mackey Villian naps,
Bro. That's what I'm talking about. Just
saying when you, when you get all, yeah,
like, oh, this guy's going
to be a Dick, you know,
and then even then you can look just
on a normal social level, you know, oh,
he's going to be dating. And you meet him
up like, uh, like, you know, movie stars,
right? Let's say they always play
a bad guy or something like that.
And this goes both ways
too. Um, and you know,
you meet the movie star in person
and they're all nice, you know,
but you see them playing the bad guy.
So you have this weird subconscious
expectation that you just love that guy or
whatever
they play there. That's how they
are. Yeah. It's like subconscious.
What do you think that those people
that play a bad guy all the time when in
real life they feel like everyone
views me like I'm a jerk,
so I'm going to be super
nice. Maybe. Maybe. But
actually,
you know what?
I actually hear more about the opposite
where it's like it's the good guy,
you know,
he's all,
he's playing the good guy or maybe on
some show or something like that guy's a
jerk. Yeah. You know, you meet
them in real life. He's not like
that anyway. Same deal. Yeah.
Expectations mean a lot is
what you're getting at. Yup.
Including leadership perspective
and napping perspective. Yes.
And meeting movie stars or
whatever. Yes. Here we go.
A prince who can command
and is a man of courage.
Undismayed an advert in,
in adversity who does not fail in other
qualifications and who by his resolution
and energy keeps the whole
people encourage such a one
we'll never find himself
deceived in them and it will be shown
that he has laid his foundations well.
Again,
this is not what people think Mackey
Machiavelli was talking about.
It's not what they think he's saying.
Build relationship. Be Strong.
Give to your people.
Continuing a wise prince ought to adopt
such a course that his citizens will
always in every sort and
kind of circumstance have
need of the state and have
him and then he will always find them
faithful. Oh, that one's a little bit.
That one's a little bit, hey mom, you
know you need, you need me here. Yeah.
That one's a little bit
machiavellian tradition. Mack. Yeah.
Continuing whoever shall fortify his
town and shall have managed the other
concerns of his subjects well and to be
often repeated will never be attacked
without. Great caution for men
are always adverse to enterprises,
were difficulties can be seen and it
will be seen not to be an easy thing to
attack. One Who has his town
well fortified and is not
hated by his people. Again,
try build relationships with your people.
That's what he's saying.
A Prince who has a strong city and has
not made himself odious will not be
attacked or if anyone should attack,
he will only be driven off with disgrace.
So same thing like if you've got a good,
if your people support you so you can
get attacked and you're going to drive
that person off,
that attacks you drive off in disgrace.
Quick one here that the arms with which
a prince defenses state are either his
own or they are mercenaries,
auxiliaries or mixed.
And we says auxiliaries. He's talking
about how if you have an ally,
you can use their troops, right? So if
you and I are allies and I'm like, Hey,
echo and be an attack over here,
you can send me some troops.
Those are my exhilarate troops.
Mercenaries and auxiliaries
are useless and dangerous.
And if one holds a state
based on these arms,
he will stand neither for from north
safe for they are disunited ambitious,
ambitious and without discipline.
Unfaithful Valeant before friends,
cowardly before enemies they have neither
the fear of God nor fidelity to men
and destruction is deferred only so long
as the attack is foreign piece one is
robbed by them and in war by the enemy.
The fact is they have no other attraction
or reason for keeping the field than a
trifle of a stipend, which
is not sufficient to make
them willing to die for you.
They are already enough.
They are ready enough to be your
soldiers whilst you do not make war.
But if war comes they take
themselves off or run from the Pho.
Yeah,
I ain't got a friend that does like
high level security and they were going,
he was going through like a high level
briefing plan if in in like a serious
disaster scenario with a high paying
client and he was basically head
incorporated into the plan,
his own family.
So okay. Echoes the High Plan Con Client.
You come to me and say, Hey, I want,
if there's a,
if there's a tr a complete catastrophe,
we're talking chem, bio,
breakout, Zombie apocalypse,
what's the plan? And he
goes, okay, here's the plan.
He came up with a plan and he put,
I said, okay, echo, here's the plan.
Here's what's going to happen.
Here's where my family is going to be.
And the guy's like, what do you
mean? You're like, Whoa, your family,
I'm not worried about your family. The
security guys, security guys said, Hey,
I'm not you guys started guys.
Yes I will be bringing my family.
And the guy's like, wait, why am, why
are you bringing your family? He says,
cause if I'm not bringing my family,
I'm not going to be there to help
you survive. And the guy says, okay,
fair enough, right? Yes. Hey,
we've got a bunker to go to.
I'll get you to the bunker, but I'm not
going to get, I'm not to leave my family.
And then you think I'm going to defend
your bunker when my family's out with the
zombies.
No.
The best thing you could possibly do
is let me bring my family in the bunker
because then I will die before I give up
the bunker. If it's just you, I love you.
I appreciate your giving me money, but
I'm going to take care of my family first.
Yeah. So think about that. It's
a squared away plan, right? Yeah.
You actually embed yourself inside my
family and you're going to be safe. Yeah.
I'll use some of your money to,
to prepare for the situation,
but then we'll be ready. Yeah.
We're all one team now. Yeah,
so that turns someone from
a mercenary into, you know,
it's just part of the team.
Continuing on.
The mercenary captains are either
capable men or they are not.
If they are,
you cannot trust them because they
always aspire to their own greatness.
Either by oppressing you who
are their master or others.
Contrary to your intentions.
But if the captain is not skillful,
you are ruined. The
usual way. Don't. Yeah,
just the usual way of being ruined.
You know what that is?
That means you just get hacked to death
on the battlefield. That's what it means.
Yeah. Lose, lose with the mercenaries.
Mercenaries. A loose, loose scenario.
Yeah. Continuing a print
ought to have no. Ah,
let's get in the zone for this one.
Uh,
a prince ought to have no other aim or
fought nor select anything else for his
study.
Then war and its rules and discipline.
Okay.
For this is the soul art that belongs
to him who rules and it is of such force
that it not only upholds
those who are born princes,
but it often enables men to rise
from a private station to that rank.
And on the contrary,
it is seen that when princes have
thought more of ease then of arms,
they have lost their states.
And the first cause of you're
losing it is to neglect this art.
And what enables you to acquire a
state is to be the master of the art.
So there you go.
That's general rules for everyone.
Study nothing but war didn't
discipline. Yes. Cool.
Yeah.
Yes it is.
It is interesting,
isn't it?
Okay,
me,
you don't have to go back that far to
where did the way things are going to be
is settled by war a hundred percent and
you could still say that's true today.
I mean, when diplomacy fails, you go
to war. Yeah. That's the way it works.
You and I can have a conversation
if that conversation fails,
what's gonna Happen?
Accreted disagree. No,
I'm not agreeing to that turns into
a scrap, so I better study. Yeah.
Now,
if,
if one of us knows that the other one
is going to win on the field of battle,
that's going to make that person a
little bit more apt to agree, right? Yes.
You know what I mean? Yeah. Or agree
to disagree, which ever, no. Well,
the one person might have to agree
otherwise they're getting choked.
All right,
so now he talks about how how you
continuing on a prince who
does not understand the art
of war over and above the
other misfortunes already mentioned,
cannot be respected by his soldiers,
nor can he rely on them.
He ought never,
therefore to have his thoughts,
this to have out of his thoughts,
this subject of war and in peace,
he should addict himself
more to its exercise.
Then in war,
this he can do in two ways.
The one by action nearby by study.
So he's saying that in peace time you
can actually addict yourself more to
exercising war then you can and war
itself. So when it's time to prepare,
you prepare even when no one will not
war going on. That's when you get ready.
You don't wait until you're
getting attacked to start training.
Jiujitsu you start now. Yeah. I've had
that argument with people that said it.
Well, the thing is it takes really
tall, long time to get good at Jujitsu.
When are you going to be
attacked? Well, I don't know.
If you get a attack tomorrow,
that's a bummer,
but you're probably not
going to get attacked. To me,
you're getting attacked in six months.
You might get attacked in a year.
You might get attacked in four years.
Yeah, you can be really good by that time.
Yeah. Yeah. There was an article,
I think you even came across it,
you might even have commented on it
online and in the article it was like some
things that you shouldn't focus on or
whatever as a man or something like this.
And uh, I thought it was a fake
article and I still think, I mean,
I don't know if it was real or not,
but whatever.
Let's just say it was real and it was
like fighting said that's the most wrong
thing of her. And I
actually agree that, oh,
I actually think that this is so high up.
I kind of agree that this,
with this statement, like you should focus
on this as being really high in your,
in your focus in life. And it really
comes down to a safety thing really.
And look, yeah, it definitely comes
down to a safe thing. I'm not,
I'm not saying like, Hey, just
studied Jujitsu, just study MMA. I,
I'm not saying that right,
because those shouldn't be your primary
interest unless you're a fighter. Right.
And there's some people
that are so into whatever,
they get sown digit Jujitsu that
the rest of their life falls apart.
I'm not recommending that. Right. Want
you to have a good, well balanced life,
but if you make Jujitsu a part of
it, it's going to be better. Yes,
it's going to be better.
It's going to adapt to everything else.
It's going to teach you about
other things. Yeah. Yeah.
And that's not to mention you can fight
a few on, not to mention Peter to,
he's like a,
he mentioned something about what was it,
it was something to do with golf.
Like basically he was saying,
you have to put all this effort in
and it's too frustrating. And I said,
wait till you tried to Jitsu and
then someone else said and he said,
that's why I'm not doing it.
Or something like that. Yeah.
Well he said something along those lines
and then I said something like, oh no,
someone else chimed in.
Hey Golf.
It doesn't teach you
anything like golf has what?
Transferable skills to life does golf
have? Hey, I'm not hating on golf.
If you like golf, cool. More power
to you as far as I'm concerned, but
you're not going to be able to take the
skills of a putt and bring them to now.
Okay, well let's, let's reach here.
I guess you will, cause you know,
you're gonna be able to relax. You're
going to learn how to get to mental focus.
So that's good. Yeah. Good. In
that perspective we'll give credit,
but direct transferable physical
techniques,
very limited. Limited. Especially when
you start comparing them to g to, yeah,
golf can give you some
of the same things that,
that like when I talk about shooting,
like when you get good at shooting,
it gives golf can give you some
of those same things cause you're,
you're under pressure,
you've got to focus,
you've got to put the last
shot out of your mind.
You've got to focus on
what you're actually doing.
You can't worry about the next shock
cause there's a lot of things that it can
help there. There's some motor
skills, some sports stuff for sure.
But I cut you off. What were you saying?
What was the thing? But I don't know.
I was, I was super hyped on whatever I
was about to say the article. Oh yeah.
So it was like fighting, you
shouldn't, you know, fight or whatever.
And what made it even worse?
A lot worse is the explanation as to why.
What was the reason why,
if I remember correctly,
it was because you shouldn't be fighting.
That's why
you only play it if you lose
your temper, you know, like, no,
you should own it in a nutshell you
say because you shouldn't be fighting,
so you shouldn't focus on, on, on
learning how to fight or whatever. Here's,
here's the, the ultimate dichotomy
in this situation. The more,
the better you can fight, the less you're
going to have to find. Exactly right.
And most of us, in fact, I would,
I'm almost tempted to say all of us,
everybody who is a trained fighter,
unless you're talking about competition,
you don't train to fight.
So you can go get into fights with meat.
No, that's not the way, the reason.
Not even like a little bit of the region.
Okay.
I can't think of anyone
that I've known in training Jujitsu
that their goal is like, Hey,
I'm doing this so I can go,
uh,
antagonize people and actually
get in to get myself into fights.
There's no one that you're right.
There's no change. I haven't, I mean,
I'm sure there's a couple complete
jerks somewhere out there that have done
that, but I haven't done any yet. And
even thinking about that, it'd be like,
that'd be weird seeing, I'm going to be
different when someone's like a bouncer.
Right? Oh, you were a bouncer.
Right. And it's like, oh,
I want to know how to handle
myself if I get into a fight. Yeah.
But you'd rather just be polite
to people until it was be polite.
Right. Until then. Be Nice until
it's time to not be nice. Yeah.
That's what I'm talking about the
way we used to do it right there.
Exactly right. Even then, by no means,
it's literally the opposite direction.
It's not so I know how to go fight guys.
You know? It's more so you know
what to do in the event of a fight.
Now, I will say this, I have to
look at this from a perspective.
When I was younger,
like before I joined the military,
there was times when we were getting in
fights just to get into fights and if
Jujitsu would have been a thing,
I probably would have been doing it.
Ah, I was just young and stupid. So were
all my friends. Right. So here and here's,
here's kind of the, I call it a dichotomy,
but I think it's more like, uh, sure.
I'll call it a dichotomy.
It's like a catch 22,
so like when you don't know how to fight,
like before you take Jujitsu. Oh yeah.
Um,
same,
same boat where it's like getting in
a fight seems more appealing when you
learned you do too. And here's the proof.
By the way, when you learned you to,
you don't really want
to do it maybe at first,
maybe at first your white
belt or whatever. Sure. But
think about this blue belt,
purple belt, Brown belt,
that, and this goes up and up.
The more you advanced get your black belt,
you've been a black belt for like what,
1314 years or something like this one.
A brand new white belt comes in.
Do you want to roll with him or you want
to roll with Andy? Andy, why Andy's good.
Exactly right.
So you want to,
you don't want to go test your skills
against some guy weird on the street.
You know you want to go practice and
learn and prove that you're like good with
other good people. You know other
people who are trained. So it's like it,
it makes no sense that want to get where
you're going with that is when you're
good or no.
Like let's say Amen to go learn how
to fight the your first Jujitsu class.
You're like, okay, I'm not going to get
any fights. You know what I'm saying?
Which is I think a very realistic thing
and I think if I was a 15 year olds old
again and Jujitsu exist and I was like
all, I'm going to go learn how to fight.
I would have gone in there one class and
I'd be like, I'm not getting any fights.
This stuff,
cause you never know who knows this
stuff because you're going to judge glass
and you get choked out by someone that
is half years or maybe three quarters
your size. Yeah. That's a scary thing.
Sunstar looking around going, wait,
who knows this? I'm not. Your
confidence goes way down when you,
well let's put your yeah,
I guess is your coffee.
It's yeah, it's absolutely
true. And I was in the, Oh man,
I felt that it was overwhelmed
because I was in like, like you said,
I was a bouncer. So even at like
when you get your blue belt,
it's like that's when you're kind of
the most fiery, I think in certain ways.
And so I'm looking around and I'm
like, yeah, you know, I could do this.
I could take that guy. He's bigger, but
I could take them like I know I can.
But then you're like, wait, what up bro?
What? Y'All don't know who that guy is,
you know, kind of be one wrestler, Bro.
What if you caught yourself or you found
yourself in a rear naked choke in a
real fight, bro, you're, you're
kind of done man. You'd be in big,
big trouble for that. Yeah.
So when you think about that
and you're like, man, yeah,
just like are you said,
Bro,
I'm not getting any into any fights
there is that this goes even further.
So this article that you're talking about
that said you shouldn't learn how to
fight because you shouldn't be fighting.
Yeah. Shitting, get into fight the actual,
if you feel the urge to fight,
the best thing you can do to quell that
urge to go learn how to fight. Yeah.
I think he said the best thing
is to go learn meditation. No,
Sam Harris, where are you at? We're
not, that's not going to help us.
I'm not against meditation,
but as a,
as a replacement for learning how to
fight and negative. Sorry man. And,
and you know what?
I've had Tim Ferris and Peter,
and I don't know if we talk about this
with Sam yet, that they think they,
they,
they impose meditation onto my
Jujitsu for me right there like that.
Is there like,
hey joc would,
the things that people are trying to
get from meditation is what you get when
you go and you do Jujitsu. Yeah.
Like your mind gets emptied,
your focused but not focused. There's all
these things and I'm sure I'm, you know,
people that are in the meditation will
say, no, you're missing it and I'm fine.
That's fine. I know I am. Whatever.
But what I'm saying is there are
some similarities. There has to be,
because Tim and Sam all,
you know, they both did.
You just do and do meditation and
there's crossover there somewhere.
Tim for sure has told
me that. Tim, for sure,
it's taught me that even
like weightlifting, you know,
even when you're trying to do a movement,
right? You're trying to do a snatch,
you're trying to do some movement that
you have to focus on that puts you,
I mean, you know what it's like when
you go to Jujitsu, you come home,
you feel so good, but you don't feel
good because of the physical workout.
You feel good because your
brain got emptied. You know?
And I think that's part of what
meditation is. I don't know, but yeah.
Well, yeah, I would think so too.
Yet. It's like an overlap. Yeah.
There's a bunch of overlap there. So
just sum this up. Learn how to fight,
right. Learn not to bake bread. Don't
listen to that Weirdo article, man.
The thing is that there's a good chance
that it was like a one of those parody,
whatever. I, I forget what even it was on.
Yeah, but it wasn't on like
a parody website. I don't,
I didn't recognize it as a parody rep
website, but I don't remember the website,
to be honest with you. I just saw
these weird things. To me it was,
it was the kind of where all of the items
on his little list or like we're wrong.
Fighting was just the one that I felt
song as a mouth and it was just wrong.
This is joke,
joke,
joke. Okay. So as I was
wrapping up that one,
he says that
that you can study war,
you can ask yourself,
it's exercise yourself in war two
different ways. He says one by action,
the other by study. Here we go. Here's
the action part. As regards action,
he ought above all things to keep his
men well organized and drilled to follow
incessantly.
The chase,
which is like hunting and patrolling
by which he accustomed his body to
hardships and learn something of the
nature of the localities and gets to find
out how the mountains rise,
how the valley's open out,
how the planes lie to end to understand
the nature of rivers and marshes and in
all of this to take the greatest care
which knowledge is useful in two ways.
Firstly,
he learns to know his country and is
better able to undertake its defense
afterwards by means of knowledge
and observation of that locality.
He understands the ease.
Any AC understands with ease,
any other which it may be necessary
for him to study hereafter because the
hills,
valleys and planes and rivers and marshes
that are for instance in Tuscany have
a certain resemblance to
those of other countries.
So that with the knowledge
of the aspect of one country,
one can easily arrive at
a knowledge of others.
And the prince that lacks this skill,
the essential which is desirable,
that a captain should possess for a,
teaches him to surprises enemy to select
quarters to lead armies to array the
battle to besiege towns to his advantage.
Yeah.
So boom, go out train. Yeah,
train incessantly,
get out there. That's what
you have to do. And now,
so that's the action part
and the other part, now here,
now we get to the study part
to exercise the intellect.
The prince should read histories and study
the actions of illustrious men to see
how they have borne themselves in war
to examine the cause of their victories
and defeat so as to avoid the
ladder and imitate the former.
Oh Wow.
Listen to this podcast. This is
what we're saying. Yeah. Read.
If you don't got time to read, press
play. Boom. Yeah. Get some. All right.
I wish I had this podcast.
Yeah.
I wish I had this podcast to listen to
when I was 17 years old when I was 19
years old,
when I was 23 years old when I was 33
years old when I was 37 years old. Yeah.
Are you kidding me?
Yeah.
That practice part is, it seems like,
oh yeah, that makes sense. You know,
but I think that, I'm not sure
if you've read the whole thing,
but it seems kind of even understated.
Cause like even when you study
something, right, you're like, okay,
I know what to do. Part seems to
understated the study part or the action.
The action part.
Yeah.
He says incessantly.
He says Dick to yourself
to exercise before.
I don't know if that's understated or
not. I didn't read it. Well, none at all.
Yeah, maybe you know, maybe
it was just me. Maybe.
I think it's just so important that that
should be the whole book. I Dunno. Okay.
Whatever. But either way. Either
way then regardless of how,
but training is so important
to you is what you're saying.
I think that actually doing it is
because without it you just lose.
I think you lose more than half.
If you consider study action and
you don't do the action part,
I think action is more than half
where it feels like it anyway.
Because like if you,
let's say you haven't done,
did you to school in a long
time or eight or anything,
you are correct when it comes to sports,
but he's talking about actual going to
war and you can't take a nation to war.
You can't even take a platoon to war.
You can't take a company to war
without going to war. So yes,
you can do the training
exercises in the field,
but there is absolutely a massive benefit
to studying what has happened in the
past. And I'll tell you from
a leadership perspective,
like if I was a business person,
I'd be reading about business business,
not so much business leadership
books that this is how to lead,
but this is what happened
in this situation.
And the perfect example for me of that
from the war perspective is about face by
Hackworth.
That book is not a leadership book,
but when you read it from a
leadership through a leadership lens,
it's all about leadership.
It's all about leadership.
And so you can take books that are
about business, not about like, hey,
this is a leadership instructional manual,
but hey, this is what happened in this.
As this company fell apart or this like
you study those books, read those books.
Then it gives you a little bit more
of an advantage. But in both fees,
what you really should be looking
for is the dynamics of human nature.
And you can figure out
like, okay, when people,
when this happened inside this company
or this happened in this battle,
people act this way. People acted that way
and now I understand them better. Yeah.
If you're seeing it for the first time,
just like we talked earlier about,
if you see, if you know an
our lock is coming, if you,
if you know how to defend an arm
lock or you know what's coming,
you at least know to pull your elbow in,
right?
If you read a book that explains what
happened in a battle or in a business
scenario and you go, okay, here's what
happened right here, I recognize it.
Maybe not exactly,
but it's close enough and I can expect
this response from the enemy or from the
competitor or from my people.
I can make an adjustment and
at least not blind. Yeah,
and that's kind of the part I was
talking about. Where were the, yeah,
that's right. And I think
that's right. Even the, the,
the inverse where it's like,
okay, you can, let's say
you study this, I know this,
you know,
I know that this is how it works,
but you've never been in the situation
to recognize how it feels, you know, in,
in, uh, you know, so like
training for war or whatever.
Like let's say in your guys' case where,
how you would always,
you say you try your
best to make the training
as realistic as possible.
So that's the actual action kind of stuff.
Even just something as simple
as roll roll plate, you know,
where it's like you're trying to simulate,
you're trying to introduce the action
part of it more so than Jay, it's study.
Sure. Got It. You know, so yeah. So when
you find yourself in the real situations,
I'll give you a case in point.
You can read extreme ownership.
You can read the dichotomy of leadership.
I'll have someone that's read and
read and studied both those books,
listen to every podcast and
roll in and be like, Hey,
let's role play this right here.
Yeah. And be like, you know,
put them in a scenario where,
where the right answer would be to say,
hey like that's my fault, here's what I'm
gonna do. Crew. And they'll, they'll say,
well the team needs to do this and
you just think yourself so you're,
you are correct.
You have to put people in the action as
much as you can because the observation
of a situation is not as effective a
learning tool as the being involved in the
situation. Yeah. I do actually agree
with you. Yeah. Cause just like in yours,
in that scenario you just kind of painted,
it's usually,
well I would imagine you could tell me
is it because their feelings almost kind
of blocked their knowledge at that
point in a way. Yes. Yes. Yeah.
So if you're in the situation,
you are now kind of familiar with the
feelings that come along with and for
instance, you have to learn how
to detach. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Too.
If you don't know how to detach
and I throw something at you,
you don't know how you'd detach cause
you know what the right answer is,
but you don't do it. You can't do it.
You don't do it. So that's, that's an,
that's a problem. So yes, put yourself,
put people, put your team, put yourself,
not just study it. Okay, here's
the, here's the, here's what you do.
You study it.
And then from the study you try and
formulate a simulation that you can put
yourself into. There you go. There's
the answer. Here's the answer.
Last little section about this.
A wise prince ought never in
peaceful times stand idle,
but increases resources with industry
in such a way that they may be available
to him in adversity so
that if fortune chances,
it may find him prepared
to resist her blows,
he's really into in the peace time,
you work harder and know what
I'm going to agree with them.
Next.
Every prince ought to desire to be
considered Clement and not cruel.
That's, again, this is
not tradition Machiavelli,
but then he says, nevertheless, he ought
to take care not to misuse this clemency.
So show mercy, but don't get
crazy beat. There's a dichotomy.
Don't get crazy with the mercy.
Does the economy be very merciful
but don't be overly merciful?
You got to be balanced. Can
be a softy. Softy, a prince,
so long as he keeps his subject United
in loyal not to mind the reproach of
cruelty because with a few examples,
so he's an hey, you should,
if you're considered cruel
sometimes that's okay. This is,
this is tradition
because with a few examples,
he will be more and more soulful
than those who threw too much.
Mercy allowed disorders to arise from
which follow murders or robberies for
these are want to injure the whole people.
Whilst those executions which originate
with the prince, offend the individual.
So every once in a while if somebody
gets out of line, you got to,
you got to kill him,
he got to execute and that is actually
going to keep the people more under
control more so they'll
discipline gives you more freedom,
a little discipline and
freedom there on that one.
I think that's the old making eggs, an
example. Sure. It's making an example,
but what he's saying is, hey, the
example and the hurts one person.
Well that's cool.
Here's the famous section when I'll read
a pretty big chunk of it. Upon this,
a question arises whether it be better
to be loved than feared or feared than
loved. It may be answered that
one should wish to be both,
but because it is difficult
to unite them in one person,
it is much safer to be feared than
loved when of the two either must be
dispensed with.
So he's saying the best thing you
could do is balanced her dichotomy.
That's the best thing to do because this
is to be asserted in general of men,
that they are ungrateful,
fickle, false, cowardly,
covetous. And as long as you succeed, they
are yours entirely. So he's saying, look,
people are kind of dastardly,
but as long as you're doing good,
as long as you're successful, you're,
you'll be fine. But, and then he says,
when you're,
when you're being successful,
he says they will offer you their
blood, property, life, and children,
as is said above,
when the need is far distant.
So as long as I'm doing good, goes like,
hey, yeah, I'll be there for you bro.
But when and approaches they turn
against you and that prince who relying
entirely on their promises has neglected
other precautions is ruined because
friendship,
this is a big critical,
a differentiation because friendships
that are obtained by payments and not by
greatness or nobility of
mind may indeed be earned,
but they are not secured and in time
of need, they cannot be relied upon.
And men have less scruple and offending
one who is beloved and one who's feared
for love is preserved by
the link of obligation,
which owing to the basis of man is
broken at every opportunity for their
advantage. But fear preserves, you buy a
dread of punishment, which never fails.
So I think one of the differences
he's talking about that when I,
when I give you money, when I treat
you well, when I, you know, Eh, em,
em, generous to you. You love
me. But that's, that's different.
That's different.
That's not like a respectful though.
Yeah.
But then, and then he says
this as well. Nevertheless,
a prince ought to inspire fear in
such a way if he does not win love.
He avoids hatred
because he can endure very well
being feared. Whilst he is not hated,
which will always be as long as he
abstains from the property of his citizens
and subjects from their
weapon. So he said, look,
you can't just run rough shot over
people and take the women and take their
property.
Hm.
But when it is necessary for him to
proceed against the life of someone,
he must do it on proper
justification and for manifest cause.
But above all things,
he must keep his hands off the property
of others because men more quickly
forget the death of their father,
the loss of their patrimony.
Cheap.
So yeah.
Firm but fair then he's seen
be firm but fair. Yeah. Yeah.
Overly from east saint from
when you have to be. Yeah.
But fair is just as important.
It's a dichotomy that you have to balance.
That's what he's saying.
He just didn't write it as cleverly.
Uh,
when a prince with his army and under
and has under his control a multitude of
soldiers,
then it is quite necessary for him to
disregard the reputation of cruelty again.
So he again, he's saying,
well, you gotta be cool.
You've got to be cool for without it.
He would never hold his army,
United or dispose to its duties among
the wonderful deeds Hannibal of Hannibal.
This one is a numerated that having led
an enormous army composed of various
races of men to fight in foreign lands.
No dissensions arose either
among them or against the prince,
whether in his bad or in his good fortune.
This arose from nothing else
than is inhuman cruelty,
which with boundless,
which with his boundless Fowler made him
very revered and terrible in the sight
of his soldiers. Revered and
terrible. There is a dichotomy.
He was revered and terrible,
but without that cruelty,
his virtues were not sufficient
to produce this effect.
Returning to the question
of being feared or loved,
I've come to the conclusion that men
loving according to their own will and
fearing according to that of a prince,
a wise print should establish himself
on that which is in his own control and
not in that of others.
He must endeavor only to
avoid hatred as is noted,
so be balanced
and he said over and over again
before this that you know,
having the connection with the
people and if the people are loyal,
like that's the most important thing.
If they hate you or if they don't like
you or if they're just afraid to you,
they don't have that,
then you think about it when you're
afraid of somebody and you have the chance
to to rise up and smash them down.
You don't want to live live in fear.
No, you do. So
next section,
everyone admits how praiseworthy it is
in a prince to keep faith and to live
with integrity and not with Kraft.
And he used that word craft
meaning like guile and sort of,
yeah.
Nevertheless,
our experience has been that those princes
who have done great things have had
good faith of little account and have
known how to circumvent the intellect of
men by craft.
And if in the end overcome
those who relied on their work.
You must know there are two ways of
contesting one by law, the other by force,
the first Methodist proper demand,
the second to beasts,
but because the first is
frequently not sufficient,
it is necessary to have
recourse to the second.
So look,
we want to do things that are a nice way,
but if we have to got
to get a little savage,
there is therefore it is necessary for
a prince to understand how to avail
himself of the beast and the
man. Again, this is a dichotomy.
You got to know that sometimes you got
to get Chris get nuts and sometimes you
got to not.
Yeah,
it is necessary for prince know how to
make use of both natures and that one
without the other is
not as durable a prince.
Therefore being compelled knowingly to
adopt the beast ought to choose the Fox
and the lion because the lion cannot
defend himself against snares and the Fox
can not defend himself against wolves.
Therefore,
it is necessary to be a fox to discover
the snares and Elian to terrify the
wolves.
Those who rely simply on the lie and
do not understand what they are about.
Yeah,
he who has known best how to employ
the Fox has succeeded the best.
No, there you go. You know,
can't just be the brick brute.
You've got to have a little bit of that,
but it is necessary to know of this is it,
this is where you get,
this is going traditional
machiavellian attitude.
It is necessary to know how well
to know well how to disguise this
characteristic and to be a great pretender
and dissembler and men are so simple
and so subject to present necessities
that he who seeks to deceive will always
find someone who will allow
himself to be deceived.
There's a sucker born every minute.
So he's saying you got to act these ways,
but you've got to cover it up, which is
going back to Richard the third, Hey,
I'm going to cover this stuff and make
it up. Make it look like I'm a saint,
but really I'm the devil. A
prince, especially a new one,
cannot observe all those things for which
men are esteemed being often forced in
order to maintain the state, to act
contrary to fidelity, friendship,
humanity, and religion. So he's saying,
look, those are the, those are the nice
ways to act, but sometimes you can't.
You can't keep it. Yeah. Therefore,
it is necessary for him to have a mind
ready to turn itself accordingly as the
winds in variations of fortune's
force it yet, as I've said above,
do not deserve diverge from the
good if he can avoid doing so.
But if compelled then to know
how to set it about, so, hey,
if you can,
you gotta be,
you maintain your fidelity and friendship
and humanity and religion if you can.
If you can't, you gotta know how
to get after it the other way.
That's what he's saying. And again,
my personal belief is if you do that,
it's going to come back. It's going
to come back. And I'm not again,
like I'm not talking about a spiritual
Karma that's going to come back.
I'm talking about real life. We'll
come back and you screw someone over,
their time will come.
When you screw enough people over,
everyone's time is going to come.
Yeah. And that, I mean doesn't,
maybe I got it wrong,
but so Jordan Peterson for example,
he'll talk about this too,
right?
Like where you have to be a good person
with the capability of being a bad
person. That's optimum. The optimum
thing is, hey you, you can get, you can,
you can bring the funder if you have too,
but you shouldn't,
you shouldn't have to.
This is not quite that.
This is saying sometimes you got
to do some underhanded stuff.
That's what he's saying.
He's saying sometimes you've got to do
some underhanded stuff and I'll tell you
back in these days,
I mean,
think about how much more
communication there is today.
You do something that's out aligned.
Everyone's going to know it was not going
to take them very long to know it yet.
Weird men, like when you see, you know,
some people they're just sorta like that,
you know and know,
you know,
it's almost like they can't see very far
ahead of themselves or something like
that. Like they'll like,
oh yeah, yeah, yeah,
they're just shortsighted and they just
screw this guy over and screwed that
person over.
And next thing you know,
they look up and they wonder
why they didn't get hired.
Or they wonder why they
didn't get the contract.
didn't get promoted. It's
like, oh, guess what you did?
And it's so, it's almost like a thought,
like, well shoot, I didn't like,
I didn't screw you over you like, why
are you acting like this kind of thing?
Or why are you treating me like
this? Like I'm some, uh, you know,
Fox or clever, what craft
person or whatever. Um,
but meanwhile everyone's seen what you're
doing now just because you didn't do
it to me. No, Bro. We know what
kind of person. One of the,
one of the hardest things for some
people is they think that they're a fox.
They think that they can get
one over on you and, and,
and they just, they just, it's
so obvious. Like you said,
it's so obvious you're looking at them
going, hey man, everyone, not just me.
Everyone can see. And you
know what, sometimes people,
not everyone can see what
they're doing and if you're,
and they think they're getting away
with something and you're looking at him
going, man, I can see right through what
you're doing. Why are you doing this?
Yeah. Cause I can see exactly
what you're doing. Yeah.
And the fact that you're doing it and I,
I you don't think I can see that
you're doing it. It proves two things.
Number one, you don't think I'm very
smart and number two, you're underhanded.
Neither one of those is going to work
out for you because this is not my first
Rodeo and I'm watching what you're doing
and this is going to come back in a
very hard way on you don't do that.
Don't do that.
There's varying levels of that too.
Like he can be like real devious stuff,
you know? It can be that, but it can be
like Ooh, no harmful things to and the,
and the point there is semi harm.
You meant to say harmless.
A semi harmless things. Yeah. Some are
homeless, homeless things, but there's,
but also sometimes, and I always try
and get people to pay attention. This,
if you're under handed with me,
if you try and sneak one by me,
it's a trust violation. That's
a problem. That's a problem.
And you know what,
I'm not going to confront you but
I know you and it's even worse.
It would be better off for you if
I just came and said, hey, echo,
you know you tried to slide this one under
on the expense account and you bought,
you know,
whatever.
You took your family out for dinner on
the company credit card and I saw that
and you shouldn't do that.
That would be better than me.
You mean it'd be better for you?
Yeah.
Forget a little plants than me not saying
anything and just noting it and now
I'm tracking you.
Yeah,
because it's like all my knowledge of
that kind of gives me a foot to stand on
so I can kind of maneuver so
it can continue to maneuver.
I didn't say anything and I
won't say anything. I'll let you,
I'll let you continue to
reveal your dark arts.
My cards. Yes. Reveal your reveal,
your nature, your nature's cheating,
your nature's stealing from me.
You're all looking at me like,
like I actually did that. I'm trying to
think. Shoot. Did I do that right now?
But I'm just saying think about it,
but the point of what you're saying,
like whenever we all this year on
this discombobulated right now,
going through that expense report in
your head, boy, when people can see you,
but they can't see themselves,
you know,
even with like small stuff,
big stuff,
small stuff and one can see what
you're doing. My point is though,
not every not,
it's not always that everyone can see
sometimes not everyone can see and that
actually encourages a person to continue
their little crafty ways that they
think they're so good at.
And it's so,
when I see that happening,
it's just so disappointing.
It's so disappointing because you're not
even in a situation where you're with
me because like, oh, I bet you know, I
brought you into my house. Basically.
If someone's going to be able to
do that to me, they're in my house.
If you're in my house and
you're trying to, you know,
steal some milk from the drawer when I'm
not looking sure. Without permission.
Yeah. Yeah. Like you're trying to
sneak that thing in your bag. You can,
if you would ask me, you'd
had, you'd had a case in milk,
but you didn't ask what you thought is,
I'm going to try and get this.
That's a whole different
way things shake out. Yeah.
And I'm not even gonna say
anything to you. He's gonna live,
I'm not gonna say anything to you.
You can have that milk, that milk.
It was worth it because now
I know your nature. Yup.
So the torment is kind of not
punish snow, but okay. So no,
there won't be any
punishment. Right. But, but,
but in a year you're going
to look up and be like, Hey,
I know that we got this opportunity.
I'm saying, Oh yeah, yeah,
I took the opportunity.
Unfortunately I don't have room for you.
And the opportunity, there
you go. That's what happens.
But when you're surprised when I say
people can do to you and say, well,
you know what they say harmless ways or
semi harmless ways, of course, the teeny,
teeny, tiny things. And we said this
before, like name dropping, right?
And that goes a, that's
not, it doesn't go into dvs.
That's not necessarily a devious a
crafty thing or nothing like that,
but I'm just saying the concept of someone
doing something where we all see what
you're doing kind of thing, you know? So
he name drop someone and it's like, well,
most was part of the story,
but it's like probably we all see what
you're doing right there, you know?
But it's,
I think it's hard for us sometimes.
Like I just named dropped a
Sam Harrison, Tim Ferris. No,
it didn't feel like you
did, you know? Then again,
you did say their first and last name,
so that's kind of a symptom. No names.
I think the opposite. If I would
have said, oh well, you know,
I was talking to Tim week, me and
Sam were having a quick conversation.
That's true. Yeah. I think you told me
that before too. And you're right. Yeah,
it seems more, I guess it
depends, but yes. Yes Tim.
And then you're hoping in the back
of your mind that asked him who,
so you get to say, oh, just Tim
Ferriss, you no big deal. So maybe,
but the point is people
see what you're doing,
but sometimes it's hard for us to see
that they can see that, you know? Yes,
they're unaware.
So you get to stop and it's a sad thing.
Assume that people can see what you're
doing. There's a good lesson for the day.
Assume that the little maneuvers
that you think are all clandestine,
assume that people can actually see,
assume that people are a little
bit smarter than you think.
Assume that you're maybe not as
smart as you think you are. Yeah,
because there's little crafty moves
that you think are fooling people.
They don't,
and they reveal you.
Your nature as being underhanded and
people don't like underhanded people,
especially me. Well, you
should. It's a common thing.
Yeah. Jack. All right, moving on
for this reason. Again, we're talking
about how sometimes you have to,
you have to violate, you
have to, according to this,
sometimes people have to
act a little underhanded.
You have to act devious or whatever.
And here's what he says about that.
For this reason to prince
ought to take care of that.
He never lets anything slip from his
lips that does not replete with the above
named five qualities that he may
appear to him who sees and hears him
altogether. Merciful,
Faithful, humane, upright,
and religious. So again, this is Richard
the third and there's a whole backstory.
I'll give them Richard the third on
why Shakespeare wrote it that way,
but he definitely wrote it that way
and it clearly from that opening,
he's literally doing what
it says in this book.
Men judge generally more by
the eye then by the hand,
because it belongs to
everybody to see you,
to few to come to touch with you.
Everyone sees what you appear to be.
Few really know what you are.
And those few do not dare oppose
themselves to the opinion of many.
So how you look is how
you're going to be judged.
The prince must consider how to avoid
those things which will make him hated or
contemptible. This is not
traditional machiavellian thought.
It makes him contemptible to be
considered fickle, frivolous, a feminine,
mean spirited irresolute from all of
which a print should guard himself as from
a rock. And he should endeavor
to show his actions, greatness,
or showing his actions, greatness,
courage, gravity, and fortitude.
And in his private
dealings with his subjects,
let him show that his judgments are
irrevocable and maintain himself in such
reputation that no one can hope
either to deceive or get around him.
Good advice.
And I guess one of my points is
everything that's, so check this out.
Everything that we're saying about
how people can see what you're doing,
he's recommending that you act this way,
but no one will know.
And you just have to pretend like
you're actually a good person.
And what we're both saying is that doesn't
work. And I agree that doesn't work.
Yeah. So the idea that you're
going to be all behind the scenes,
you're going to be, you're going
to be all crafty behind the scenes,
and no one's going to catch you.
And you're just going to act
with greatness and courage
and act with gravity and
fortitude. And that's how you're gonna
Act, but you're not really not that way.
My point is that it doesn't work because
people can see through it and they will
see through it and they might not
see through it today or tomorrow,
but they'll see through it in a week
or two weeks or a month or a year.
And then you're going to be,
you're going to be undone.
That's a good word.
A prince ought to rec and conspiracies
of little account when his people hold
him in esteem. But when it's hostile
to him and bears hatred toward him,
he ought to have fear.
He ought to fear everything and everybody.
So if you're people support you,
don't worry about conspiracies.
If your people are hostile towards you,
you better be.
You better take note and well ordered.
States and wise princes have ever,
I've taken every care to drive the
nobles to desperation and keep the people
satisfied and contented for this is
one of the most important objects, uh,
prince can have, is to keep
people, keep your troops,
keep the people in the game.
There was never a new prince who is
disarmed his subjects rather when he has
found them disarmed, he's always
armed them because by arming them,
those arms become yours.
Those men who were distrusted become
faithful and those who are faithful are
kept. So, and your subjects become
Ed Harris. Now I think we're,
this really plays into from a leadership
perspective is when you get, when you,
when you are in a leadership
position and you empower people,
you give them power, it builds faith
that builds trust, it builds it and,
and the power that they,
that you give to them becomes yours.
We, the more powerful you
make your subordinates, the
more powerful you become.
Yeah.
If you have the ego that you can put
in checks so that you don't mind giving
some of that power away because
it'll come back to you 10 fold.
And here's what happens on the other end
of spectrum when you disarmed them at
once,
you offend them by showing that you
distrust them either for cowardice or for
want of loyalty. And either of these
opinions breeds hatred against you,
and because you cannot remain on armed,
it follows that you turned to mercenaries,
which are a character which aren't
of a character already shown.
So once again,
if I take your power from you,
then that's offensive.
Yeah. So be careful. Give,
try and give people power.
Don't take it away from them.
It takes a high level of lead security
and confidence with your own leadership
that you can give it away.
The more you're more confident you are,
the more you can give it away.
The more paranoid you think people
are going to be better than you.
The harder it is. Give it away. The
worst leader you are, the worst leader.
You become the worst situation,
the less power you have.
Just trying to hold it off for yourself.
Hmm.
Continuing the best possible fortress
is not to be hated by the people,
not traditional machiavellian fought.
The best possible fortress is
not to be hated by the people.
Okay.
Yeah, it seems like a good
start. It's a great start
because although you may
hold the fortress yet,
they will not save you if the people
hate you. The fortress isn't gonna.
If people hate you, the fortress isn't
gonna help. Don't even bother. Oh,
you built up a great fortress. Cool. We're
gonna go. We're gonna seed you. Yeah.
Cause we ain't no water,
no food.
Huck and fire over the walls continuing.
Nothing makes a prince so much esteemed
as great enterprises and setting a fine
example.
Set a good example,
not traditional
machiavellian. Ooh, good one.
The choice of servants is of no little
importance to a prince and they are good
or not according to the discrimination
of the prince and the first opinion which
one forms of a prince and
of his understanding is by
observing the men he has
around him.
And when they are capable and faithful,
he may always be considered wise because
he has known how to recognize the
capable and to keep them faithful.
But when they are otherwise,
one cannot form a good opinion of him
for the prime error which he made wasn't
choosing them. So people, your team,
people look at you and they judge
you by what your team is like.
And if you surround yourself with people
that are incompetent and incapable,
that's what people are going to think you.
So use caution.
Next when you see the servant,
uh,
when you see the servant thinking more
of his own interests then of yours and
seeking inwardly his own
profit and everything,
such a man will never make a good servant,
nor will you ever be able to trust him
because he who has the state of another
in his hands ought never think of himself,
but always have his prints and never pay
any attention to matters in which the
prince is not concerned. So if you got
someone that's thinking of themselves,
you cannot trust them.
Yeah.
On the other hand,
to keep his servant honest,
the prince ought to study him,
honoring him, enriching him,
doing him kindness,
sharing with him the honors and cares.
And at the same time,
let him see that he cannot stand alone.
So that many honors may not make
him desire more many riches,
making wish for more. And that many
cares may make him dread chances,
so what's the best way to have loyalty
with someone get treat them really,
really well. You enrich them. You on rum,
you share the honors that you get with
that person and then he throw it has to
throw in a little dig which is you got
to make sure they understand that they're
not going to get that by themselves.
He always throws a little dig in there a
little bit. He distrust people, you know,
he says it a bunch of times.
People are scoundrels basically.
Oh important section.
How flatterers should be avoided.
I did not wish to leave out an important
branch of this subject for it is danger
for it is a danger from which princes
are with difficulty preserved unless they
are carefully, unless they are
careful and discriminating.
It is that of flatterers of those of
whom courts are full because men are so
self complacent in their own affairs and
in a way so deceived in them that they
are preserved with difficulty from
the past and if they wish to defend
themselves,
they run the danger of falling into
contempt because there is no other way of
guarding oneself from flatterers except
letting men understand that to tell you
the truth does not offend you.
You gotta make sure people understand
that. If you tell me the truth,
I'm not going to be offended.
But when everyone may tell you the truth,
respect for you,
a Bates,
then he throws him the little
slumped and little counter, right?
He doesn't want people talking smack to
him, but he wants me to tell the truth.
Therefore,
a wise prince ought to hold a third course
by choosing the wise men in the state
and giving them only the liberty of
speaking the truth to him and then only of
those things which he
inquires and have none others.
So you can talk the truth
as long as I ask you before,
but he ought to question them upon
everything. But even though I say, Hey,
well you only to echo, you only
tell me the truth when I asked you,
but I'm going to ask you everything and
listen to their opinions and afterwards
for form his own conclusions with these
counselors separately and collectively,
he ought to carry himself in such a way
that each of them should know that the
more freely he shall speak,
the more he shall be preferred.
The more you tell me the truth,
the more I'm going to like it.
The Mormon alike you outside of the east,
he should listen to no one pursue the
thing resolved on and be steadfast in his
resolutions.
He who does not otherwise is either
overthrown by flatterers are so often
changed by varying his opinions
that he falls into contempt.
He continues on to this thought, a prince
therefore on always to take counsel,
but only when he wishes
and not when others wish.
He ought to rather discourage everyone
from offering advice unless he asks it.
But however he ought to be a constant
inquirer and afterwards a patient listener
concerning the things which
he has inquired also on
learning that anyone or on
any consideration has
not told him the truth.
He should let his hangar is anger be felt.
And if there is someone who thinks that
a prince who conveys an impression of
his wisdom is not through his own ability
but through good advisors that he has
around him beyond doubt,
they are deceived because this
is an axiom which never fails,
that a prince who is not wise
himself will never take good advice.
So if you look at someone and say,
Oh oh that that CEO is doing a good job,
but that's because he's got these
guys with them, that's actually wrong.
The CEO's got that good
personal with them,
those good people brought them in and
then listens to them. They get credit.
He gives him credit for that. And you know
what's funny? That's good salesmanship.
Listen to this.
Therefore it must be inferred that good
councils whatsoever they come are born.
Of the wisdom of the prince and not the
wisdom of the prints from good counsel.
So he's saying, if you're listening
to what I'm saying right now,
that makes you good.
If you listen to this book or you listen
to the words I'm saying and you obey
him, that makes you great. It
you're not giving credit to me.
You're great if you do. Yeah. What?
Like you're smart because you're so smart
to listen to the good stuff that you
taking this advice proves that
you're brilliant you. It's like, Hey,
if you read this book,
it proves that you're smart.
Just the only a smart
person would be this book.
Smart person would take the advice of
someone else. That's how smart you are.
That's like good salesmanship of the book.
Do not let,
do not let her prints is accused fortune
for the loss of the principalities
after so many years. Possession. Okay, so
he's saying don't let, don't blame luck.
Don't blame bad luck when
you lose your principality.
Don't blame bad luck,
but rather their own slaw off because
in quiet times they never thought there
could be a change.
It is a common defect in man not to make
any provision in the calm against the
tempest. So it's common that people,
when things aren't going bad,
they just kicked back the cruise cruise,
they crews and instead of working
and when afterwards the bad times came,
they fought of flight and
not of defending themselves.
And they hope that the people disgusted
with the insolence of the conquerors.
Conquerors would recall them. That's a
good plan. Hey, if I get run over run,
I'll just hope that the conquerors are
so bad that the people rebel and bring me
back.
And here he talks about what fortunate
again, he uses fortune like luck.
What fortune can effect in human
affairs and how to withstand her.
I will hold it to be true.
That fortune is the arbiter of
about one half of our actions,
but that she still leaves us to direct
the other half, perhaps a little less.
So he's saying, look, luck has
50% 50% that's a big number.
Yeah, and you might go, well, if it's
50% man, why even try? Well that's,
it leaves you 50% in control.
That's actually a lot.
He goes on, I compare her and he's hers,
yet he's talking about is fortunate.
I compare her to one
of those raging rivers,
which when the F in flood overflows the
planes sweeping away trees and buildings
bearing away the soil from place to place.
Everything flies before it all yield to
it's violence without being able in any
way to withstand it.
And yet though it's nature be such,
it does not follow.
Therefore,
that man,
when the weather becomes fair shall not
make provision both with the fences and
barriers in such a
manner that rising again,
the waters may pass away by canal and
they're forced be neither so unrestrained
nor so dangerous. So floods are
real bad and they'll wipe you out.
But when there's no flood and you can
build walls, you can build barriers,
you can build canals,
and then you can control that,
that danger,
that flood continuing on.
So what happens with fortune,
who shows her power,
where valor has not prepared to resist
her and thither she turns her forces
where she knows that barriers and defenses
have not been raised to constrainer.
So that bad luck, if you don't work
that bad luck's coming at you. Yeah.
It's common at you.
Kind of like the weather, right?
Remember like how you were saying yes.
Like it kind of like extreme ownership
almost situation where it's not Kinda,
it is a straight up, straight
up. Yeah. Like yeah. You know,
but let's say I put a TV outside
right outside, it'd be cool.
Um, you know, it doesn't
really rain much here,
so I don't really need to put on a cover
every day, you know, kind of thing.
And then sure enough, the one day
out of the year it rains on your TV,
no more TV scene was saying, but if
you would have prepared properly. Yeah.
Even though it's sunny, you just
keep the cover on anyway, you know,
just in case it rains. Good one.
Yeah. Yeah. That's, you know,
to me that was the perfect example.
You know,
I think there's a majority of people
will find that. Perfect example,
one last, last little thing to close
this out and he goes into some, um,
some more kind of historical
documentation and examples,
but this was a good one. So I just
wanted to close it out with this.
A prince may be seen happy today and
ruined tomorrow without having shown any
change of disposition or character.
And what that's saying is normal face,
you just need to keep like regardless,
things are going great,
things are going bad, guess what?
We're sticking with normal. No,
that's how we're sticking.
Hmm.
And that wraps up the book
again a ton to think about.
A ton that does.
There's,
there's definitely parts of it that
match kind of the traditional Mackey and
valley machiavellian.
Okay.
Common perception. And there's
plenty of it that goes against it.
And I believe the right answer is balance
and it's more balanced than people
think it is. Yeah. But speaking of,
you know,
bolstering up our defenses against
the whims of fortune or misfortune,
you know, do you have any maybe
suggestions on how we could
sure bolster and prepare for that a yeah.
Yeah,
a few ways. Uh, well, back to the
book real quick in, so let's say,
to sort of sum up what,
what is a way to sum up
Macchia Vallian ways? Well,
like I said, the, the,
the traditional understanding and
meaning of the word Machiavellian is a
negative. It means, hey, this person's
under handed. They're going to deceive.
They're not going to care what kind of
destruction they leave in their path.
That's what people think of it.
Like I said, if, if you say, hey,
this person's a machiavellian
leader. Everyone thinks, okay,
they're going to be merciless.
They're going to just run
rough shot over everyone.
They don't care who they step on to
get to rise to power. That's the truth.
That's the truth.
That's what the word actually means.
But we just gave example after example.
It's not that cut and dry
and he definitely introduces
many dichotomies to to
that idea that you're just going to do
whatever it takes to get to the top.
He talks a lot about these other more
moderate and important things that you
need to do as a leader to get,
not only to get in a position to
but to stay in position. So being,
having good relationships
with your people,
making sure they understand
where you're coming from.
Like these things are not
considered when you hear the word,
when you don't know any better and you
just take the word for what the word has
become, demean what the word means.
Now machiavellian is like, Hey,
I will stop at nothing to rise to the top.
And that's one of the reasons why I wanted
to cover this, because even with that,
even though he definitely leans in that
direction and he, he, what he's saying is,
look,
sometimes you gotta,
sometimes you gotta stab or somebody in
the back occasionally and then you've
got to cover it up to the best of
your ability. That's what he says.
I don't believe that. I believe in, when
you stab someone in the back, that person,
they may die, but they got a, they
got a friend, they got a brother,
they got someone else.
I got someone else's you don't know,
you don't recognize and at some point
they're going to come and get you.
So you have to, you know, you have
to try and balance these dichotomies.
You have to try and,
and that's not even balancing a dichotomy
that's just straight up like, hey,
you got to take,
you've got to treat people,
you got to respect people and you've
got to not always look out for your own
good.
And what I will tell you and what I know,
the more you look out for your own good,
and this is where,
this is probably the biggest dichotomy,
dichotomy with this
machiavellian attitude.
The more you look out for your own good,
the worst off you're going to be.
And the more you look out for the good
of others and the more you look out for
your team and the more you
put the mission and your,
and your people ahead of yourself, the
better off you'll end up in the long run.
So that's in complete contrast to what
the Makaveli and the common thought about
being machiavellian. And I, and I will
tell you, when I work with companies,
the leaders that put their
people ahead of them,
the leaders that put there that put
the mission ahead of themselves,
they're always respected.
They're always,
they're always loved by the troops.
They always have support of the troops
and they always go forward and do a good
job. The people that screw the
people over, screw the team over,
put themselves ahead,
their egos, those people,
those leaders never end up
doing well in the long run.
Sometimes you can do some
short term stuff, right? Hey,
I'm going to screw echo over them to
get promoted because I'm going to,
you know, fill out a report
that he didn't, you know,
the government to rat him out on this
thing. Okay, cool. I rat you out.
But what I don't realize is that you
have another friend that's with us.
That's that you'd, that's your peer. Yeah.
And now he's watching me and there's
going to be competency for him to rat me
out cause I miss something
or I didn't do something.
So if you form good relationships,
if you put your team and your mission
and you put others above yourself,
you're going to end up in a much better
position than you will stabbing people
in the back and stepping on people to try
and rise to the top. And not only that,
when you get to the top,
you will be much more comfortable,
not only when you look
yourself in the mirror,
but also when you get to the top and you
know that the people below you in the
chain of command actually want you there
and actually will do anything to defend
your position up there.
That's a lot more comfortable than having
to constantly look behind your back
and see who's sneaking up behind you.
So do the right thing for the right thing.
Be Good leader. Yeah, keyword is good.
So kind of in a way it
kind of goes along well.
Really does go along with kind
of what you say were like,
so okay,
machiavellian way traditionally whatever
could be put simply maybe over simply
but simply, you know, looking
out for yourself. Totally.
You know, kind of thing.
Look out from what you say and what he
ends up saying is the best way to look
out for yourself to look up for the piece.
Always talking about the people and
people don't get the people. So man,
it's kind of brings it
full circle in a way.
It does bring it full circle and the
full circle answer is take care of your
people, take care of your team,
look out for other people.
Don't put yourself first. Yeah. If you do
that, you're going to end up, you might,
like I said,
you might end up stepping up for a moment,
but in the long run things
aren't going to go your way.
And even when you are on the top,
you're going to be waiting
to get stabbed in the back.
Not Fun always in.
The more,
more I think of a new kind of turned me
on to the whole idea of the long game.
The more I kind of opened my
eyes to like look at things.
It kind of seems like playing the
short game isn't the smart game.
It's totally ignorant.
Yeah. The short game.
So when you figure it and you can see
it to where it's so obvious when people
are playing the short game.
We, yeah. With everything.
With everything. Yeah. In fact,
if you identify any one of your failures
or the failures of others, whatever,
but try your own.
If you identify any one of them,
you'll probably trace it down to your
playing the short game in regards to that.
Many times you're overweight or whatever
you're playing the short game as far as
like what you eat,
what you're doing physically or
whatever you playing short during.
You can go to the short term payoff
rather than the big long term. Big. Yeah.
So if you can maintain that in your mind,
I think play the long game,
he'd be doing some good stuff.
Yeah. My opinion, it's a,
it's a weird dichotomy that if you really
want to do well yourself and the best
thing you can do is take care of,
you know,
you're being someone who's not yourself.
Yeah, exactly. It's a dichotomy,
but it's the reality. It's, it's a,
it's a nice little blessing that
you get at the end of the day for,
for trying to take care of people.
They'll take care of you,
you take care of people, they'll take
care of you. Then to go one step further,
if you take care of yourself and give
yourself the capability of the Kate,
take care of more people seem to saying
so. It's like this never ending. Well,
if you take care of, if you
looked at this, this is the, no,
this is the opposite of what I just said.
The opposite of what I just said is if
you take care of yourself as the primary
right,
you will end up being in a worse position
than if you try and take care of other
people. Yeah. That's the,
that's the reality. So if I'm,
if I'm always looking out for me,
if I,
if I act in the traditional
machiavellian way,
sure I might get a head right now I might
step on am I get a short term win here
and their longterm I will not be
in a better position long term.
I will be in a worse position.
Yeah. That's the way it is. Yeah.
I was thinking more, you know, the
oxygen mask in the plane, you know,
put it on yourself before your
kids kind of thing. But you know,
it's a tall thing,
nevermind.
But every once in a while,
every once in a while you can find
something that has both a short term and a
long term payoff.
Jujitsu is one of those things.
Okay.
Short term,
longterm indeed big time.
Are there sacrifices? Why wouldn't you
take Jujitsu? And I'm not saying like,
Oh you know you, I'm just
saying what are, what are.
So in general I don't have time,
number one. Number two, there's all,
then we want you,
once you get past that one,
it's just a whole array of
reasons I might get hurt.
I don't like,
I feel claustrophobic,
which by the way is an even more reason
to do it because you should be trying to
overcome that. Um, what, what other
yeah, she uses general intimidation,
intimidation or whatever. Yeah.
I don't try something new.
That's kind of like a big thing.
Scary. Yeah. It's scary. I'm scared.
Need to read Mikey and the
dragons, but go ahead. Nonetheless,
if when we see fit to start Jujitsu,
if we haven't started already,
you're going to need a g and a rash card.
Maybe some other stuff. No. G and
a rash guard. Perfect. Yeah. Yeah.
The school and then, yeah, the academy or,
or at least some mats and a friend
or at least a friend at these.
Okay. Okay. Yeah. Better
than nothing for sure.
But when you get the g and people, yes.
People still ask what kind of, Gee,
should I get? Just started. What
kind of origin? G from origin,
origin, main.com. This is where you
can browse as many Giza as you want.
Get more than one. Um,
best keys. Factually.
The best keys made in America
from beginning to made in America.
Getting to the end of the whole process
designed by people that do Jujitsu.
Yup.
Not by a random person that doesn't train,
not by a person that looked an
Ikea Yogi and said, oh yeah,
well that's no Ughi. That's
a person that says, oh shit,
I do Jujitsu daily and I need
to make the best possibility.
I compete in Jujitsu and I'm going
to make the best possible gay.
That's where you get there. That's
where you get the origin. Geetha boom.
There you go. You're welcome. And then
we're going to make it in America. Yeah.
I wish I knew that
before I bought my first,
my first Gig I bought from the academy.
Did I buy it from the get it? Yeah.
How about it from the Academy
of the boxing club? Yeah.
It was the worst guy ever had ever.
And here's the thing,
and that's what these are
like. Yes, no, I didn't know.
So then I bought like I went
and I saw one from a guy,
a guy had one on and I was like, oh,
that looks cool. The logo look school.
Even when I felt that, I was like,
Ooh, that looks, feels beefy.
I went and got mine and it was like it
shrunk a little bit too much and it was
like it didn't fit that
good. He was like, uh.
There were some scenarios where it felt
like a straight jacket and which you
know, it depends on who you are, whatever,
but it was just so thick and maybe
might've been too small. I don't know.
But nonetheless, no one pointed me in the
right direction. That's the point. Yes.
Now you're being told, so
now, now you are telling,
telling some don't want to
be in a straight jacket. No,
you don't want to be in a
very comfortable, comfortable,
which you are highly skilled at assessing.
Coming from lionizing is big time,
but here's the thing. In Jujitsu,
if the g is comfortable, that's
a good thing. I mean, hey,
if you're some weirdo savage who's like,
you know what?
That's going to be part of my training
to put on an uncomfortable gete and
hardened my mind. There was this whole
fish to train with a wetsuit under.
His gig was for discomfort level.
Dar Tanium.
He's still a Jujitsu guy is out there.
He was like Higgs Higgs.
His training partners. Birkin.
Yeah, but he's still out there.
So is that Kinda like the the guys
who were the restrict oxygen mask?
Well,
you don't put on a wetsuit very often,
but ever wetsuits are slightly,
especially this is,
this is 20 years ago that that this guy
was putting on a wetsuit and training
and wetsuits have come a long way.
They're much more comfortable
now and much more pliable,
but back in the day we would put on a
three millimeter wetsuit. It was, it was,
it was restricting your mobility.
So just do that and train and be
hot and sweaty and uncomfortable.
That's next level.
Put a wetsuit on underneath your origin.
Want more discomfort. There's your,
there's your answer. Oh, right.
If you're training for that,
I say 100% don't do that.
That's what I would recommend. No,
I know you wouldn't recommend that,
but it is kind of hardcore.
It is hardcore. I,
there's a certain legitimate level of
respect I have for [inaudible] or doing
that thing. That's Kinda,
he's out there man in Jujitsu.
Just strong as hell. Just
wearing a wetsuit. Good. Amen.
Legit league. There's other
stuff at origin to, yeah,
like t shirts and sweatshirts and,
and by the way,
we're going to have jeans. We have
jeans right now while we do well I do,
cause I, I last time I looked, I
don't know. You don't have a break.
You will get some soon.
But anyways,
just like the Biggie is awesome.
Here's the problem with a g,
you can't wear a geek to the store.
You can't wear a Geeky to the
restaurant when you can't technically,
but you wouldn't do that. So, you
know, talking to Pete, I'm like, Pete,
I love, I love my origin. Geese.
I will in origin g around the house
maybe a little bit, right? I said, Pete,
I can't go out. I need, I need, I need
jeans. I need something. And jeans.
Guess what you can do in jeans.
We're up to the restaurant.
You can wear them anywhere. You can swing
a hammer. When you're wearing jeans,
you can pour concrete.
When you're wearing jeans,
you can go to a restaurant when
you're wearing jeans or Jean jeans,
origin genes coming
very soon.
We will have them available on the website
to preorder where I think we're going to
be like a preorder thing just cause we
want to know how many to make.
But yeah.
Then we'll just start making them as
fast as we can. So made in America, uh,
what the denim without compromise,
the buttons.
American. Wait, what are
those things called that you,
that you fastened at the top of the
genes buttons. The buttons. They will,
the bras are made in America.
Everything's made in America and they're
sewn up in Maine by serious craftsmen.
Legit crafts, crafts people. Yeah.
American denim.
Then straight up bringing it back,
bringing it back or gin main
origin may doll supplements
because you're on the program right
now. Back on the program. My art,
like come back in Jujitsu.
My arm is healed but it's like really
susceptible to tendonitis, you know,
like this kind of,
especially with a twisting stuff.
I don't know if I'm ready for like any
kind of legitimate d situation. But,
so after training you get stiff by just
pound joint warfare, Krill oil, whatever.
Next day I'm like, cool. But the day
after that good to go man. It's like,
it's amazing nonetheless.
But yes, joint warfare,
joint warfare is what it is for
your joints. Keeps it together.
Krill oil, same deal discipline.
Just I've been on the discipline.
You drew a little bit,
you said to me like,
cause yesterday I turned kind of and
that Jujitsu and you said you were asking
me what kind of Jujitsu training feels
best and then you named a couple times a
couple different types and then one
them you said was like a three scoop of
discipline day level.
Like the highest level.
That was the highest
level of good Jujitsu Day.
It was three scoops of discipline.
Yeah. Which by the way,
you can get in tropic thunder
flavor now. Yeah, I'm on that.
We're waiting for a cease and
desist level letter from uh,
from Jack Black who is in tropic thunder.
Robert Downey Jr and Robert Downey Jr.
Yeah.
And bench still stiller.
Well until then,
until then, we're just going to
make it tropic thunder. It's good.
I actually liked that flavor very much
and I like the uh,
you know, the cognitive enhancement.
Some star, I'm just do the three.
I'm going to try the three and back on
the program and do the three Oh three
scoops of disagree. Scoop two
scoops the other day. It's good.
Liked it. What day? Paid off
Wednesday. Okay. What about
Sunday? Yeah, Sunday. Sunday.
So the other day,
Sunday a little bit.
I sensed a little bit of urgency.
Yes. He made me move.
I was pretty impressed.
It's actually the best I can
hope for right now. But Hey,
we're doing it one step at a time.
You know, we're moving forward. Also,
if you want some additional
protein in addition to your steak,
steak or Sushi,
whatever,
whatever your Gig is,
drink milk,
drink it every day if you
have to. Okay. I have,
I have talked about this before,
but I stepped it up. Okay.
So you can also get warrior kid milk,
which is for kids. It's got, it's,
it's the best possible
thing you can feed a kid.
They edited this out when a tie was down
doing the the the week in the life of
Jocko.
Sure.
I was like I said something
along the lines of, hey,
when you're feeding your kids,
when you're feeding your kids a soda,
that's child abuse.
I was going off but so that's why I
made work at some warrior couldn't walk
because I have a bunch of kids myself
and it's really hard to get kids to eat
good food because either you don't have
time to prepare it or you're running
late or you whatever or so we
made warrior kid mark. Yeah.
Here's the thing, it tastes delicious.
Here's what I did yesterday. My daughter,
she was making her dessert strawberries.
I said, here, let me, cause
she usually takes strawberries.
She puts a whipped cream on it and then
she sprinkles wore your kid mark on the
top, like a little
dusting. It's really good.
We had no whip cream
yesterday. So I said, hey,
we got some heavy whipping
cream and I've done this before,
but I actually got the tool out.
The proper mixing tool that spins
real fast. What's it called?
Well there's a bunch of them,
but the one that I am familiar with
is called the magic wand. Okay.
Mine wasn't that or no,
this is like an oil that's electric.
It wasn't gas powered,
but it just like the traditional thing
that you saw in the 50s a little two
little things that spin together
and yeah, like an egg. Okay.
So I'm sitting there with the egg beater.
So I put in heavy whipping cream and then
I put two scoops of Strawberry Warrior
kid milk. Whipped it,
dude. It's ridiculous.
It's completely ridiculous. And then,
and then put that on strawberry jam.
It's like a whipped cream. It's
like whip cream, whip cream.
So this is a whole nother thing.
This might start a whole nother sort of
cultural revolution in this nation from
our children when they are eating
warrior kid and whipped milk cream.
It's amazing. So anyways, give
that a try. Interesting that.
Yeah, the egg beater. Well
the man, you know what the
magic wand is? It's, it's not,
it's like maybe from the 80s. It's
like a, it looks like, Oh yeah,
you just stick it in your drink.
You can make like mail or whatever.
But from what I understand,
I dunno. Nonetheless,
it would have been interesting to imagine
you with one of those cause it is kind
of a dainty apparatus.
So get some of that and get some of
that milk for your self or your children
both fall on origin main.com.
Also Jocko has a store,
it's called Jocko store,
Jocko store.com.
So this is where he can get more rash
guard rash guards that represent the path
and put a new rash guard on there.
Kind of obvious ones saying, uh,
stand by to get some because
it applies to Jujitsu anyway,
some new stuff.
I was wearing a rash guard when I was
working out this morning when I was,
when I do, uh, when I do a lot of
ring work, when I'm using the rings,
sometimes you know, you get
the chafe going on, right?
There's the straps on sometimes on this
particular day and I did have a rash
guard on this morning.
Good. Also t shirts,
shirts on there represent truckers,
hats and flex fit by the way or beanies.
Sure. Check patches on there. I know
we were out of patches. We were,
oh, okay. Sorry. I should have
done a better job of paying
attention to that. Yeah,
no, no, no, no. It was my fault
in not enough completely my fault.
This is what I'm going to do
to rectify or did more patches.
We got more patches in
at this time.
Also some women's stuff on there,
some hoodies on there.
It's basically if you want to represent
the path that you're on that we're on.
Boom. That's where you
can do it. Clothing wise,
chocolate store.com that's how I see it.
That's all I see it as a whole.
That's what it is and
subtle representation of
the path can also be done.
Yes.
On that store you can check it out
for yourself and see some subtle
representation of a, yeah,
deep. How should I say?
D representation.
You know
chuck? Yeah. Chocolate Store
Corp Com and Jocko white tea.
What up with it?
Tastes delicious is
completely good for you.
Isn't it weird that people
would make foods that are
not completely good for you?
But yet most people make foods that
are not completely good for you. Yes.
Jocko white tea is completely good. Real
well, it goes beyond accidents. Yeah.
Tastes delicious.
Got a little caffeine.
A little hitter is not going
to get you crazy. Is Not a,
it's not an energy drink
that makes you psychopath,
makes you addicted to
caffeine. No, it's not that.
It gives you a nice little hitter, a
little caffeine hit her Theo. Yeah.
Well, yeah. I mean, I wouldn't even
say this. The caffeine is significant.
It's not nothing. No, it's 60
milligrams. That's, that's,
that's lower than a cup of coffee.
Two thirds of a cup of coffee. Yeah.
That's solid. Good. Yeah. You feel it,
but it's actually good for you. And that's
the thing, going back to, uh, you know,
the short term, long term or
long game. Short game. Yeah.
That's the reason people
sell food, drinks, whatever,
that are not good for you because they're
selling to the short game players.
Yeah, he's good with all
the the sugars and whatnot.
Don't get on that path. No, no,
we're not playing that game anymore.
Jocko white tea.
You can get it with tea bags or
you can get it with an a can. Yes,
and I have lots of cans and I just
crack them open and get after it.
And you see everyone already knows that
you get an 8,000 pound dead lift with
that.
So check there.
It is available on Amazon and the
store also subscribed to the podcast,
blah blah blah.
No waiting for you.
That also check out the
warrior kid podcast. You might,
you probably know about this podcast
because you're listening to it.
You don't know about
the warrior kid podcast.
The warrior could podcast
is awesome I think.
I think so too.
So check out the warrior kid podcast.
Also check out warrior kids soap at Irish
oaks, ranch.com. Yoga, young aid news,
a warrior kit up there, making
soap, building a business,
creating a brand.
Yup.
But most of all milking goats and
turn it into something usable.
That's what I like. Working
hard. They get right? Yeah.
That's what I'm talking about.
Don't forget about youtube.
We have a youtube channel.
It's called Jocko podcast.
Yes, yes. Called Jocko podcast. This
is where echo puts all these videos.
He puts them on there,
including these full podcasts and
including excerpts and including enhanced
excerpts that he goes oh crazy with his
old digital CGI stuff and to make things
explode. Sure. Sometimes
also psychological warfare.
He didn't know what that is. I
know. We all know what that is.
We're waiting for a
psychological warfare too,
but in the unlikely event that you
don't know what it is, this is what is,
it's an album with tracks.
Jocko tracks Jocko talking to you,
telling you, telling us really
how to get past these moments,
a weakness. Cool. In our
journey on the pole, lifting,
waking or whatever we got to do.
I gave you let you talk about that.
Why now and you know what? You don't
want to rely. I figured this out.
This is why you're like, yeah. He's like,
yeah, that's what it is. Boom. Move on.
Kind of kind of attitude. You know
why? Why? Because you don't use that.
You're not going to put,
you're not going to play the MP
three of yourself telling yourself,
well I don't know, maybe do,
but I don't think you do.
You already had that MP3 embedded
in your brain or anything. In fact,
that's what it is. It's literally what
it is. But I do, so I know that. Yeah.
You know more than me.
Cause it's weird because sometimes
I do and it's sort of like,
it's Sorta like the,
the discipline goes freedom field manual.
I did write that book, but sometimes
I have to refer to it. Yeah.
Sometimes I have to refer to it
and I'll tell you what, it's good.
It's good to be able to refer to something
that actually states in no uncertain
terms, the direction of the
path and where you need to walk.
We need to move. It's very, it is very,
there's a lot of clarity in it and
that's powerful to be able to refer to
something back like that, you
know? Yeah. So fully. Yeah.
So psychological warfare, same
thing. When I listened to it,
it definitely has an impact.
There's no doubt about it.
When you get psychological
warfare and you click it,
it's going to get through to you.
It almost like,
and I'm trying to imagine this
right now, like let's say, okay,
you know how the night before you might
have this problem might not on and off,
but the end of the night
before you're like, Hey,
I know you probably don't actually,
hey,
this is what I'm going to do
tomorrow I'm going to take care of,
take care of business.
I'm gonna work out this at this time
and I'm doing something to do this.
And then tomorrow comes and you're like,
Dang,
I'm kind of not in the mood for that. So
I'm just going to, I won't do that today.
I'll,
I'll skip that.
I'll opt out of that today cause
I'm not in the mood or whatever.
But what if you,
if you have like an audio file
of yourself telling you, hey,
this is why you should do this.
Yeah, it would bring you back.
I think even if it's yourself
know, huh? Interesting.
Interesting little phenomena.
Never explored that. Nonetheless.
Good psychologic warfare.
It's called psychological warfare.
It's on Amazon. Itunes. Where we
can get the artist is Jocko Willink.
The artists psychological where
warfare two is going to be released to,
to be, to be decided DVD.
First track is going to be,
don't hesitate in making
psychological warfare to her ass.
I can play it to myself. Deal. Anyway,
also near path on the path
we're working out. Boom.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash Jocko
this is where you can get more or whether
it be workout equipment or you know any,
anything that you might need to add
to your capability and workouts.
Health knowledge on the path.
This is where you go.
Go on it.com/jocko good stuff on
there. Really good stuff, Scott.
Some stuff together.
Speaking of stuff,
forgot Mikey and the dragons book for
kids all ages between three and 300 so you
can get that. You can get where
the warrior kid and Mark's mission.
Two books teaching kids
how to be on the path.
You've got discipline equals freedom.
Which I just talked about
teaching adults how to go on
the path and stay on the path.
The audio that is on iTunes.
I'm Amazon music, Google play,
extreme ownership.
The first book that I wrote
with my brother Leif Babin,
it's about leadership and that is followed
up by the dichotomy of leadership,
which actually goes granular on
the nuances of extreme ownership.
So check that one out and we'll real
quick back to Mikey and the dragons.
This what's good about this book
and I was talking about life,
talking with life about it this morning,
eight applies it to everything for a
kid because kids have to think about it
when you're a kid, what are you
when you're a kid facing the world,
everything is hard.
Everything is scary. Yeah.
And so you have all these fears to
overcome and miking the dragons,
lace leaf throws that at his son says,
Hey,
got to face these dragons and fire it
up. You know? And that's what you do.
You learn these lessons
and it's a life lesson.
So Mike and the dragons get some
of that. What else? Echelon Front.
Speaking of life.
This is our leadership consultancy and
what we do is solve problems through
leadership. Me, Lafe, Bab and JP to Dave
Burke, Flynn Cochran, Mike [inaudible],
Mike [inaudible].
If you're having problems with your team,
with your company,
with your organization,
with your business,
and you want to turn
those problems around,
the problems are leadership problems.
That's what they are.
Every problem you have
is a leadership problem.
Go to echelon front.com if you want us to
come and help you solve those problems,
we solve problems to leadership.
The muster. Speaking of leadership,
there's a leadership conference event
that we have 2019 May 23rd and 24th
Chicago,
September 19th and 20th Denver,
December 4th and fifth Sydney,
Australia.
Go to extreme ownership.com if you
want to come to one of those events,
they have all sold out and
these are gonna sell it.
The last one we did in San Francisco,
they've all sold out,
but the one we just did in San Francisco,
I had people calling me 10 days out,
personal friends that were like,
hey,
just want to bring three people from my
team. And I'm like, oh, that's cool. No,
you can't come. We have a fire code. We
cannot bring you into the building. Stop.
Don't, don't come. Because you know, you
know some people just figure you're like,
oh, you can just squeeze me in
there. I actually can't do that.
They're all, they all have sold
out. They are all going to sell out.
So go there and register
as quick as you can.
Eff Online is live is launched.
What is that?
I'll tell you what,
if you can't make it to a muster or you
can't afford to go to the muster or you
can't afford to bring 12 people from
your team to the muster f online,
that's what e f online is.
We the original intent of f online was
to be able to train people without having
them have to come to the muster.
Give them the same experience,
give them the same knowledge about having
to come to the muster. So we did it.
And Eff, online.com
interactive. You get the briefs,
you get to go through
scenarios. It's, it's powerful.
It's way more powerful than
I thought it was going to be.
And I thought it was going to be good,
but it's better than I thought
it was going to be. Yeah, it's,
it's interesting too, because I went
through, I went through it, you know,
it was like, oh yeah, you
know, like cool. This is like,
just like when we talk about at the muster
or what you guys, what I listened to.
And then it's cool because at sort of at
the end of, of the sections or whatever,
there's like a little quiz.
I think the way the thing came out and
we're continuing to work on it and work,
continue to upload new modules. So
like, oh, and what's, and the other.
So one of the reasons
that we made it was to,
was to help people that weren't coming,
that couldn't have come to the roster,
whether they were overseas and
they couldn't afford it. I didn't,
couldn't get time off.
The other major demand signal was we work
with giant companies that have 100,000
employees and one particular company with
over a hundred thousand employees said
to me, Hey, well we want you to
train every employee we have.
And this was two years ago and I didn't
have a good answer for him and I don't
like having to not having a
good answer. Right? Yeah. Oh,
you want me to travel globally for the
next six months to all your different
factories?
And it wasn't six months.
It was probably gonna take three and
a half months or something like that.
That's not feasible. Like I can't
just go off the grid everywhere else.
Not Recording podcasts, be traveling
the world, training people. Right.
That's not going to happen. So what are
we going to do? You have online? Yeah.
And so we've got an enterprise with it
to where you can have your whole company
training and it's awesome. It's awesome.
So good. Get your people in line.
That's the half online and of course
one last thing. Do you have Overwatch?
This is us connecting proven lead combat
leaders from special operations and
from combat aviation and we're bringing
them into companies that need leadership
in their organization
to get problems solved.
Go to e f overwatch.com you want
people that know and understand extreme
ownership,
no one understand the laws of combat.
No one understand how to balance
that economy of leadership.
Go to e f overwatch.com whether you're
a person that's trying to hire or a
person that's trying to get hired,
if you're one of those vets,
go and sign up there and if you have
anything to communicate with us,
we can be found on the
interwebs, on Twitter,
on Instagram,
and on that fee she bookie echo is at
echocharles in I am at Jocko Willink.
And finally,
thanks to all of our military personnel
out there for training hard and for
holding the line as always
against evil around the globe.
And also thanks to our uniform
personnel here on the home front.
And that includes police
and law enforcement,
firefighters and paramedics in the mts
and correctional officers and border
patrol in all first responders.
Thank you.
And to everyone else out there,
like Machiavelli says in his book,
not the one that you've heard about,
but what he actually says,
guard yourself from flattery
by demanding the truth,
especially with truth from yourself and
choose good people to be around you.
And set a good example by acting with
courage and gravity and fortitude
and study the art of war.
Yeah,
it's rules and it's discipline and keep
your body accustomed to the hardships.
Yeah.
And exercise your intellect with reading.
And last but not least,
even when the weather is fair.
Yeah.
In fact,
especially when the weather is fair,
make provisions.
Okay.
Build defenses and barriers and dams
and canals and protection protections
against the rising waters of misfortune.
So even when things go wrong,
you are ready to get out there
and get after it.
And until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.